In Toronto, every arrival is a statement, and nothing says it better than this. Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025. Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19-speaker AKG surround audio system. This city demands agility, and Optic delivers with precision to make every drive extraordinary. Let's take the Cadillac. Find out more at Cadillac Canada.ca. Luxury sales claim based on S&P Global Mobility Canadian New Vehicle Total Registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury. So it happened that Marius was selected to command the war against Mithridates in place of Sulla.
在多伦多，每一次抵达都是一种宣言，而没有什么比这更能说明问题了。凯迪拉克Optiq是2025年加拿大销量第一的豪华电动汽车。通过无缝的33英寸显示屏和沉浸式的19扬声器AKG环绕音响系统，找到您的节奏。这座城市需要敏捷，而Optiq以精准的表现让每一次驾驶都非同凡响。让我们选择凯迪拉克。在CadillacCanada.ca了解更多。豪华车销量声明基于标普全球移动（S&P Global Mobility）2025日历年加拿大新车总注册量，符合凯迪拉克对豪华车的定义。于是，马略被选中接替苏拉指挥对米特里达梯的战争。
When Sulla was brought the news of this, his instinct was to rely on military force to oppose his demotion, and so he summoned his men to an assembly. They were all desperate to fight Mithridates, since the war promised them a great deal of plunder, and they were worried that Marius might recruit other soldiers in their place. Sulla spoke to them of how disgracefully he had been treated by Sulpicius and by Marius. And while he did not openly allude to his secret intention, since he was nervous how this might go down with the soldiers, he urged them to prepare for such orders as he might give them. The soldiers, however, perfectly understood his meaning.
当苏拉得到这个消息时，他的本能是依靠军事力量来反对他的降职，于是他召集了他的部下进行集会。他们都渴望与米特里达梯作战，因为这场战争承诺给他们带来大量的战利品，而且他们担心马略可能会招募其他士兵来取代他们。苏拉向他们讲述了苏尔皮基乌斯和马略是如何无耻地对待他的。虽然他没有公开暗示他秘密的意图，因为他担心士兵们会如何看待这件事，但他敦促他们为他可能下达的命令做好准备。然而，士兵们完全理解了他的意思。
And since they were anxious not to miss the campaign against Mithridates, they boldly articulated for Sulla what he had hesist. to put directly into words, then told him to be of good courage and to lead them on to Rome. Sulla was delighted by this and promptly set out with his six legions for the city. All his senior officers, however, saving only a single Quistour, deserted him, since they refused to be complicit in an attack on their own country. As for Sulla, when envoys from Rome met him on the road and asked him why he was marching with his legions against his native city, he answered, to deliver her from tyrants. So, what an extraordinary moment. So that's an
由于他们急于不错过对米特里达梯的战役，他们大胆地为苏拉表达了他犹豫不决而不敢直接说出口的话，然后告诉他要鼓起勇气，带领他们进军罗马。苏拉对此感到非常高兴，并立即带着他的六个军团出发前往该城。然而，除了唯一的一名财务官外，他所有的资深军官都抛弃了他，因为他们拒绝参与攻击自己的国家。至于苏拉，当来自罗马的使者在路上遇到他并问他为什么要带着军团向自己的祖国进军时，他回答说，是为了从暴君手中拯救她。那么，这是一个多么非凡的时刻。所以这是一个
account by Aryan, the Greek historian, and he's writing about one of the landmark moments in all Roman history, one of the most melodramatic moments in all classical history. We're in 88 BC, and it is the decision by a Roman commander to lead an army for the very first time against Rome itself to attack his own capital city. Tom, this is a monumental moment in Roman history and you could argue a key step in the process that leads from the Roman Republic to, in a century's time, the launch of the Roman Empire under Augustus. So why don't you fill us in on the circumstances that have brought us to this extraordinary point. I mean, it really is that fateful.
希腊历史学家阿里安的记载，他正在书写罗马历史上最具里程碑意义的时刻之一，也是整个古典历史上最戏剧性的时刻之一。我们现在处于公元前88年，一位罗马指挥官做出了一个决定，这是历史上第一次带领军队对抗罗马本身，攻击他自己的首都。汤姆，这是罗马历史上一个具有纪念意义的时刻，你可以说这是从罗马共和国走向一个世纪后奥古斯都领导下罗马帝国建立过程中的关键一步。那么，你为什么不向我们介绍一下导致我们走到这个非凡时刻的情况呢？我的意思是，这确实是命中注定的。
It is, as you say, a stupendous moment. And the circumstances that have led us to this point, we covered them in our previous two episodes, but just to give a synopsis. So we've been talking about this venomous rivalry between the two greatest generals in Rome. There's the old bruiser, Gaius Marius, and there is the man who had once been his lieutenant,
正如你所说，这是一个惊人的时刻。导致我们走到这一步的情况，我们在前两集已经讲过了，但只是做一个概要。我们一直在谈论罗马两位最伟大将军之间这种恶毒的竞争。一个是老拳手盖乌斯·马略，另一个是曾经担任他副官的人，
who is lucius. ruthless, much younger than Marius, and much posher. So this is Sulla, who is a patrician. And the Romans have been fighting a very brutal war against their own Italian erstwhile allies for three years. And by 88, it's not yet over, but the Romans are by now on the front foot. At one point, it's looked very bad for them, but they've made a really, really good recovery. And Sulla has been the great hero of this war. And his reward has been that the people have voted him consul, which is the highest magistracy in the Roman Republic, and it's been the great object of Sulla's entire political career to get it. But the consulship has also won him something
也就是卢修斯。冷酷无情，比马略年轻得多，也更讲究。所以这就是苏拉，他是一位贵族。罗马人已经与他们自己的意大利前盟友进行了三年的残酷战争。到了88年，战争还没有结束，但罗马人现在已经占据了主动。有一次，情况对他们来说看起来非常糟糕，但他们已经取得了非常、非常好的恢复。而苏拉一直是这场战争中的大英雄。他的回报是人民投票选他为执政官，这是罗马共和国最高的官职，这也是苏拉整个政治生涯的伟大目标。但执政官职位也为他赢得了某种
perhaps even more valuable. And this is a command against a king in what is now Turkey. It's a region called Pontus abutting the Black Sea. And the king of this area, the king of Pontus is called Mithridates. And he has invaded the Roman province of Asia, which abuts the Aegean sea. And astoundingly, he has driven the Romans into the Aegean. Now, to get this command is the great prize in Roman politics at this point. Because in Rome, it is universally assumed that Eastern King, oriental despots as they would describe them, are vicious but fundamentally effeminate. And they are also sensationly rich. And so the command against Mithridates seems to promise whoever has it very easy pickings.
可能更有价值的东西。这就是针对现在土耳其境内一位国王的指挥权。这是一个叫本都的地区，毗邻黑海。这个地区的国王，本都国王被称为米特里达梯。他入侵了毗邻爱琴海的罗马亚洲行省。令人震惊的是，他把罗马人赶进了爱琴海。现在，获得这个指挥权是当时罗马政治中的大奖。因为在罗马，人们普遍认为东方国王，也就是他们所描述的东方暴君，是邪恶的，但本质上是软弱的。而且他们也极其富有。因此，针对米特里达梯的指挥权似乎向拥有它的人承诺了非常容易的收获。
So glory and riches, which for any kind of self-respecting Roman commander is the absolute, you know, essence of what you want. And so this is why it's not just Sulla who wants to go. off and have a crack at Mithridates. It's his men as well. I think this is why they're so keen to follow him when the command gets stripped from him. Of course, what has happened? We ended the last episode. There has been a great twist. So Gaius Marius, that's Sulla's old commander, you know, his old patron in some ways, I suppose. But of course, now his great rival, Marius, who is basically Elvis Presley, circa 1972. He is living on the, like, seafront real estate. He's been stuffing himself with, you know, I don't know,
所以荣耀和财富，对于任何有自尊心的罗马指挥官来说，这绝对是你想要的本质。这就是为什么不仅仅是苏拉想要去挑战米特里达梯。他的部下也是如此。我认为这就是为什么当指挥权被剥夺时，他们如此热衷于跟随他的原因。当然，发生了什么？我们结束了上一集。有一个巨大的转折。所以盖乌斯·马略，那是苏拉的老指挥官，你知道，在某种程度上是他的老赞助人，我想。但当然，现在是他伟大的竞争对手，马略，他基本上就是1972年左右的猫王。他住在海滨房产上。他一直在塞满，你知道，我不知道，
what he's at. Oyster burgers. Oysters, surely. Despite the fact that he's 69 and that he is a thousand stone, he wants the command himself, doesn't he? You talked before about Marius from a provincial background, this gnawing need for fame, for success, to stick it to the elite who've looked down on him. And Salah is part of that elite. Right, exactly. So that enhances a sense of rivalry between them.
他在吃什么。牡蛎汉堡。肯定是牡蛎。尽管他已经69岁了，而且重达千斤，但他自己想要这个指挥权，不是吗？你之前谈到马略来自省份背景，那种对名声、对成功的渴望，为了打击那些看不起他的精英。而苏拉就是那些精英的一部分。对，完全正确。所以这加剧了他们之间的竞争感。
And I think also we've been eluding throughout this series to a prophecy supposedly given to Marius when he was a boy that he would come to hold seven consulships, which would be a record total. And so far he's only had six. So I think that Marius may well be dreaming of that elusive seventh consulship as well. And Marius and Sala absolutely detest each other. And Marius's hatred for Sulla has grown because he now feels put in the shade by the person who was formerly his deputy. And there's a sense in which that kind of resentment is the most toxic of all, the resentment of someone who had always been preeminent and who now finds himself being put in the shade by someone that he'd always slightly look down upon. So what Marius does, Sulla is away. He's besieging this town called Nola in Campania beside the Bay of Naples.
而且我认为我们在这整个系列中一直在暗示一个预言，据说马略在还是个男孩时就被告知他将担任七次执政官，这将是一个创纪录的总数。到目前为止，他只担任过六次。所以我认为马略可能也在梦想着那个难以捉摸的第七次执政官职位。马略和苏拉绝对痛恨对方。马略对苏拉的仇恨加深了，因为他现在觉得被曾经是自己副手的人掩盖了光芒。在某种意义上，那种怨恨是最有毒的，一个一直处于卓越地位的人，现在发现自己被一个他一直稍微看不起的人掩盖了光芒。所以马略所做的是，苏拉不在。他正在坎帕尼亚那不勒斯湾旁边围攻一个叫诺拉的城镇。
Marius seizes his chance while Sulla, the consul, is absent from Rome. And he teams up with this tribune called Sarpicius, who presents a bill to the Roman people. And by the terms of this bill, Sulla is to be deprived of his command, and Marius is to get it. And the plebiscite is duly passed. It becomes law. And Marius sends one of his staff officers to inform Sulla of this plebiscite. but more than that, to take command of his army on behalf of Marius. So Marius' staff officer rides from Rome down to Nola, and he arrives in Sulla's camp.
马略趁苏拉这位执政官不在罗马时抓住了机会。他与一位名叫苏尔皮基乌斯的保民官合作，向罗马人民提出了一项法案。根据这项法案的条款，苏拉将被剥夺指挥权，而马略将获得指挥权。公民投票如期通过。它成为了法律。马略派他的一名参谋去通知苏拉这个公民投票。但不仅如此，还要代表马略接管他的军队。所以马略的参谋从罗马骑马到诺拉，他到达了苏拉的营地。
And Sulla has with him six legions, of which five are earmarked to go with him on the expedition against Mithridates. So this is about 30,000 battle-hardened men. in total. And listeners at this point may be wondering, well, if Sulla has six legions with him, how many legions does Marius have with him in Rome? And the answer is Marius has absolutely no legions whatsoever. So you would think this is pretty basic maths. How can, as hardened an operator as Marius has always been throughout his life, how could he possibly have been so stupid as to drive his greatest rival into this corner where there are six legions kind of at his back. This seems to, I would guess, completely mad to people today listening.
苏拉带着六个军团，其中五个被指定随他一起参加针对米特里达梯的远征。所以这大约是30,000名久经沙场的士兵。总共。听众此时可能想知道，好吧，如果苏拉带着六个军团，马略在罗马带着多少军团？答案是马略根本没有任何军团。所以你会认为这是非常基本的数学。像马略这样一生中一直如此强硬的操作者，怎么可能如此愚蠢，以至于把他最大的竞争对手逼到这个角落，那里有六个军团在他的背后。这对于今天听的人来说，我想是完全疯狂的。
But is there not, I mean, I'm going to hazard a guess at the answer to this, which is that marching in Rome has never been done before. And you say Sulla has the legions, but the legions, you know, Sulla's borrowed the legions from Rome. They're not his personal legions. We're not in the first century or second century AD. the absolute convention surely is that Sulla just says, fine, I don't like it, but I'll, you know, I'll have to go along with it. And off he goes back to Rome.
但难道不是吗，我的意思是，我要对这个问题的答案进行猜测，那就是进军罗马以前从未做过。你说苏拉有军团，但军团，你知道，苏拉是从罗马借来的军团。它们不是他的私人军团。我们不是在公元一世纪或二世纪。绝对的惯例肯定是苏拉只是说，好吧，我不喜欢它，但我，你知道，我将不得不顺从它。然后他回到了罗马。
You know, you don't want to earn the opprobrium of your fellow elitists in Rome who would, you know, it's unthinkable, basically, that you wouldn't obey the order, isn't it? I think for Marius, it is literally unthinkable. He hasn't even crossed his mind, because as you say, it is, it goes against every custom tradition and law of the. Roman Republic, the notion that an army of Rome might choose to behave like the private militia of its own commander. It's just unthinkable. Imagine when Harry Truman sacked Douglas MacArthur in the Korean War, imagine if Doug General MacArthur had caught his troops and said, fine, we're marching on Washington. I mean, it's that level of unthinkability, right? Yeah, I think so. Or, you know, Montgomery marching on London in 1944 or something.
你知道，你不想赢得罗马其他精英的谴责，他们会，你知道，基本上不可想象，你不会服从命令，不是吗？我认为对于马略来说，这简直是不可想象的。他甚至没有想到这一点，因为正如你所说，它违背了罗马共和国的每一个习俗、传统和法律，罗马军队可能选择像其指挥官的私人民兵一样行事的概念。这简直是不可想象的。想象一下哈里·杜鲁门在朝鲜战争中解雇道格拉斯·麦克阿瑟，想象一下道格·麦克阿瑟将军召集他的部队说，好吧，我们要向华盛顿进军。我的意思是，这是那种不可想象的程度，对吧？是的，我想是这样。或者，你知道，蒙哥马利在1944年向伦敦进军之类的。
something. I mean, it would be an insane thought, and that's why it doesn't occur to Marius that it's remotely possible. But of course, it does occur to Sulla. And what is striking is that he doesn't seem to have hesitated at all. I mean, there's no kind of standing on the backs of a Rubicon thinking, oh, should I or shouldn't I? He just goes for it. And I think this reflects a number of factors. So firstly, Sulla knows that his men think he's absolutely brilliant. Sulla, all his life has used his charm when he chooses to as a weapon. And I don't think it's any different with the Rankin Far Legionaries. They are ready to follow him basically wherever he leads. Sulla is charming, but he is also a very, very dangerous man to offend. And although he's a very good looking
之类的。我的意思是，那将是一个疯狂的想法，这就是为什么马略认为这根本不可能。但当然，苏拉想到了。令人震惊的是，他似乎一点也没有犹豫。我的意思是，没有那种站在卢比孔河边思考，哦，我应该还是不应该？他只是去做了。我认为这反映了许多因素。首先，苏拉知道他的部下认为他非常出色。苏拉一生都在选择时利用他的魅力作为武器。我不认为普通军团士兵有什么不同。他们准备跟随他基本上无论他去哪里。苏拉很有魅力，但他也是一个非常、非常危险的人，不能冒犯。虽然他是一个非常英俊的
man, people have noted throughout his career that when he gets angry, mysterious white spots start to appear across his face. And when these white spots start to appear, it's a lot of it's probably not a good sign. So I think that's something very ominous and a clear marker that Sulla is not a person that you want to put into a strop. On top of that, as we've said, Sulla has a deep personal rivalry with Marius. He really detests him. He is furious at the frustration of his ambitions and of a deal that he thought was absolutely done.
人，人们在整个职业生涯中都注意到，当他生气时，神秘的白点开始出现在他的脸上。当这些白点开始出现时，这可能不是一个好兆头。所以我认为这非常不祥，是一个明确的标志，表明苏拉不是一个你想让他发脾气的人。最重要的是，正如我们所说，苏拉与马略有深刻的个人竞争。他真的痛恨他。他对自己的野心受挫以及他认为绝对完成的交易感到愤怒。
And so he therefore has an utter belief. in the justice of his own cause. And this matters because Sulla above all is very superstitious. He believes that he is what the Romans called Felix, Lucky, a favourite of the goddess Venus. And so he trusts on fortune, on Venus, on everything that is right and proper, that they will back him, that they will give him the good luck that Sulla regards essentially as his kind of divine right. Can I ask a question? So in later years, it was quite common for generals to think that their armies belong to them. So Pompey the Great, Caesar, Krasas, you know, Anthony, Octavian, these commanders who end up fighting for supreme power in Rome and, you know, taking the city, being kicked out of the city, retaking all of this.
因此，他完全相信自己事业的正义性。这很重要，因为苏拉最重要的是非常迷信。他相信他是罗马人所说的“费利克斯”（Felix），即幸运者，女神维纳斯的宠儿。所以他相信命运，相信维纳斯，相信一切正确和适当的事情，他们会支持他，他们会给他苏拉本质上视为他某种神圣权利的好运。我可以问一个问题吗？所以后来，将军们认为军队属于他们是很常见的。所以庞培大帝、凯撒、克拉苏，你知道，安东尼、屋大维，这些最终为罗马最高权力而战，你知道，占领城市，被赶出城市，夺回所有这些的指挥官。
And that's a result, obviously, of the structural circumstances. You know, this isn't their own willfulness. This is just what people do at this point. Sulla's the first person that does this. Now, is this, as a way, great man history, Sulla could have decided differently. This is about his own individual, you know, genius or whatever. Genius is the wrong word, but you know what I mean. Or is it that by this point, Roman politics has degenerated.
这显然是结构性环境的结果。你知道，这不是他们自己的任性。这只是人们在这一点上所做的事情。苏拉是第一个这样做的人。那么，这是一种伟大的历史，苏拉本可以做出不同的决定。这是关于他自己个人的，你知道，天才或什么的。天才这个词用错了，但你知道我的意思。还是说到了这一点，罗马政治已经退化了。
It's already begun to corrode the partisanship, the polarization or whatever, which makes it possible for him to make this decision. So in other words, is he genuinely thinking completely outside the box? or if he hadn't done it, somebody else would have done it pretty soon afterwards. I think there are all kinds of circumstances, but there are two obvious ones. And the first is that as Rome's supplies of manpower have grown larger, and as campaigns require armies to be away and in the field for longer, so the opportunities for individual commanders to establish a personal link with their men
它已经开始腐蚀党派之争、两极分化或任何东西，这使得他能够做出这个决定。换句话说，他是在完全跳出框框思考吗？还是如果他没有这样做，很快就会有别人这样做。我认为有各种各样的环境，但有两个明显的。首先是随着罗马人力供应的增加，以及战役需要军队在野外停留更长时间，个人指挥官建立与部下个人联系的机会
and identify their own interests with those of their men starts to grow. So I guess that what Sulla decides to do is something that a general at some point in Roman history was almost bound to do. And on top of that, political life in Rome has been quite brutal over the previous decade. So that we talked in the first episode, two tribunes were murdered. Sulla himself was menaced by heavies when he went back to Rome as consul. And so there is a kind of a coarsening, I think, of the traditional respect that the Romans had. for their kind of constitutional norms. But having said that, I mean, those constitutional norms remain very, very strong.
并将自己的利益与部下的利益等同起来的机会开始增加。所以我猜苏拉决定做的事情是罗马历史上某个时刻的将军几乎必然会做的事情。最重要的是，罗马的政治生活在过去十年中相当残酷。所以我们在第一集谈到，两名保民官被谋杀。苏拉本人在以执政官身份回到罗马时也受到强人的威胁。所以我觉得罗马人对他们的宪法规范的传统尊重有一种粗糙化。但话虽如此，我的意思是，那些宪法规范仍然非常、非常强大。
And when Salas leads his legions on Rome, the news of his advance is greeted with utter shock and consternation. People cannot believe what has happened. And I think the fact that it hadn't crossed Marius's mind, it's the kind of the best indicator of how still at this point it was basically seen as something inconceivable, except for someone as bold and ruthless as Sulla. So as he leads allegiance towards Rome, everyone in Rome is going, what the hell's going on?
当苏拉带领他的军团进军罗马时，他推进的消息受到了极大的震惊和惊愕。人们无法相信发生了什么。我认为马略没有想到这一点的事实，是它在这一点上基本上被视为不可想象的事情的最好指标，除了像苏拉这样大胆和冷酷的人。所以当他带领军团向罗马进军时，每个人都在罗马说，到底发生了什么？
What's happening? And they send envoys out to beg Sulla not to cross this kind of, dare I say, sacral, boundary which encloses Rome called the Pomerium. And to cross that for a citizen in arms is an utter taboo. No one ever does it. But Sulla dares to do it. He brushes all the appeals aside. his soldiers cross the Pomerium
发生了什么？他们派出使者恳求苏拉不要越过这种，我敢说，神圣的边界，它包围了罗马，被称为波美里乌姆（Pomerium）。对于一个武装公民来说，越过那个边界是一个绝对的禁忌。没有人这样做。但苏拉敢于这样做。他把所有的呼吁都撇在一边。他的士兵越过了波美里乌姆
into the sacred space that is Rome itself and they start pushing through the narrow streets and as they do so their fellow citizens who are appalled by what is happening clamber up the stories of their various houses up onto the tops of the insuli, the blocks of flat
进入了罗马本身的神圣空间，他们开始穿过狭窄的街道，当他们这样做时，对正在发生的事情感到震惊的同胞们爬上了他们各种房屋的楼层，爬上了公寓楼的顶部
and start hurling tiles down at their fellow citizens these legionaries as they are advancing through the streets and for a moment the legionaries quail I guess they maybe they're stunned to be greeted by such violence and maybe there's a kind of a wave of shame and anxiety. But Sulla does not allow them time to think. He orders archers to dip their arrows in fire and then to fire these arrows
并开始向他们的同胞，这些正在穿过街道推进的军团士兵投掷瓦片。有一瞬间，军团士兵畏缩了，我猜他们可能被这种暴力所震惊，也许有一种羞耻和焦虑的浪潮。但苏拉没有给他们思考的时间。他命令弓箭手将箭浸在火中，然后发射这些箭
at the roofs where the people are throwing tiles down. And flames begin to crackle and spread down the line of the city's highways, these highways that the legionaries are marching down. And as they go, Sulla follows them and he is riding down the greatest of all the highway ways, the broadest road in Rome. It's called the Via Sacra, the Sacra Way. And he advances into the very heart of Rome where the Senate House stands. And he orders his legionaries to stand guard on the Senate House. The city is his. The unthinkable has happened. A general in arms has made himself the master of Rome. And just to emphasize, I mean, this is such an incredibly fateful step. And having taken it, Sulla moves very, very fast to take advantage of what he's done. He can't afford
射向人们投掷瓦片的屋顶。火焰开始噼啪作响，沿着城市的公路蔓延，这些军团士兵正在行进的公路。当他们走的时候，苏拉跟着他们，他正骑马沿着所有公路中最伟大的一条，罗马最宽的道路。它被称为圣道（Via Sacra）。他推进到罗马的心脏地带，参议院大楼矗立在那里。他命令他的军团士兵在参议院大楼站岗。这座城市是他的。不可想象的事情发生了。一位武装的将军使自己成为了罗马的主人。仅仅强调一下，我的意思是，这是一个极其命中注定的步骤。采取了这一步，苏拉行动非常、非常快，以利用他所做的事情。他负担不起
not to. He still takes the political and legal side of things seriously, doesn't he? Because he wants basically political and legal sanction for what he's done retrospectively. Yes, completely. And this is always the case in coups, isn't it? That a coup will work if the person who conducts the coup can present himself as being on the side of legitimacy, because that then transforms the former defenders of legitimacy into rebels. I mean, you see it throughout the course of history. And so it is now in 88 BC in Rome. So the key for Sulla is to have Marius and Salkius this tribune who had presented the bill to the people to have him stripped of his command.
不这样做。他仍然认真对待政治和法律方面的事情，不是吗？因为他基本上想要对他所做的事情进行追溯性的政治和法律制裁。是的，完全是。这在政变中总是这样，不是吗？如果进行政变的人能够将自己表现为站在合法性的一边，政变就会成功，因为那会将以前的合法性捍卫者转变为叛乱分子。我的意思是，你在整个历史进程中都能看到这一点。所以现在在公元前88年的罗马也是如此。所以苏拉的关键是让马略和苏尔皮基乌斯，这个向人民提出法案的保民官，剥夺他的指挥权。
He wants them declared public enemies because then Sulla can frame everything that he's doing as a defense of the Republic. And so Sulla is there in his armor in the Senate House telling them this is what you've got to do. everyone in the Senate is well aware that he has his soldiers outside and so unsurprisingly, they do indeed proclaim Marius, Marius's son and nine other of his leading henchmen outlaws. And the death squads then start fanning out. Salpicius is betrayed by a slave. He is hunted down and murdered. But the other 11 outlaws do manage to get away.
他想让他们被宣布为公敌，因为那样苏拉就可以把他所做的一切都描绘成对共和国的捍卫。所以苏拉穿着盔甲在参议院大楼里告诉他们这就是你们必须做的。参议院里的每个人都很清楚他在外面有士兵，所以不出所料，他们确实宣布马略、马略的儿子和他的其他九名主要亲信为逃犯。死亡小队随后开始散开。苏尔皮基乌斯被一名奴隶出卖。他被追捕并谋杀。但其他11名逃犯确实设法逃脱了。
Marius briefly tries to resist with his own attempted armed force. it's obviously not going to work. So he slips away and he vanishes and he is not caught. And clearly for Sulla, this isn't, it's probably an annoyance rather than a catastrophe. I mean, he's now the master of Rome, but he would really like to have dispatched Marius. And the fact that Marius is still out there somewhere. Well, that is a factor that will continue to be a feature of the story as it develops. So for the time being, he's master of Rome and we've already talked about how his priority is to establish his own legitimacy.
马略短暂地试图用他自己的武装力量进行抵抗。这显然行不通。所以他溜走了，他消失了，他没有被抓住。显然对于苏拉来说，这并不是，这可能是一个烦恼而不是灾难。我的意思是，他现在是罗马的主人，但他真的很想除掉马略。而马略仍然在某个地方的事实。好吧，这是一个随着故事发展将继续成为故事特征的因素。所以目前，他是罗马的主人，我们已经谈到了他的首要任务是如何建立自己的合法性。
to present himself as the guardian of the Constitution, to present Marius as the person who's a threat to it. And we talked in the previous episode about how Sulla, you know, golden-haired, swashbuckling, ruthless, sort of sexy, he is the candidate, the personification of the traditional conservative elite, isn't he? Well, except that he has just much of hope. He has, of course, but it's not unheard of for reactionaries or conservatives. I mean, I think of, I don't know, Spain in 1936, General Franco, people to launch coups in defence of what they claim is the old order. And that's what he's doing now. And it's incredibly Roman, incredibly Roman, to be, if you're going to be a revolutionary, to be a revolutionary, to be a revolutionary in the cause of the status quo.
将自己表现为宪法的守护者，将马略表现为对其构成威胁的人。我们在上一集谈到苏拉，你知道，金发、侠义、冷酷、某种性感，他是候选人，传统保守精英的化身，不是吗？好吧，除了他刚刚希望的那样。他当然有，但对于反动派或保守派来说，这并非闻所未闻。我的意思是，我想到了，我不知道，1936年的西班牙，弗朗哥将军，人们为了捍卫他们声称的旧秩序而发动政变。这就是他现在正在做的事情。这非常罗马，非常罗马，如果你要成为一名革命者，要成为一名革命者，要成为一名为了现状而革命的革命者。
Which is exactly what Sulla is. And on the other side of that equation are the people that Marius has been appealing to. Now, Marriott, it's interesting, why the people, why don't more of the people of Rome take to the streets? I mean, his constituency are the popularis, are the kind of ordinary people. So presumably this isn't a city under occupation. Most people in Rome are on Marius's side? Probably the mass of the population, if asked, would be pro Marius. But the key players in Roman politics, as ever, are the elites, the people in the Senate.
这正是苏拉所做的。而在等式的另一边是马略一直在呼吁的人。现在，马略，这很有趣，为什么人民，为什么没有更多罗马人民走上街头？我的意思是，他的选民是平民派（popularis），是那种普通人。所以大概这不是一个被占领的城市。罗马大多数人站在马略一边？可能大多数人口，如果被问到，会支持马略。但罗马政治中的关键参与者，一如既往，是精英，参议院里的人。
And most of them, I mean, they disapprove of how Sulla has done it. but they do approve of what Sulla has done. The senatorial conservatives really dislike the kind of the populists, if you like. And so they do approve of the measures that Sulla is taking essentially to kick Marius out of the city. Resentment of him has been, you know, long term. He's very, very unpopular with the senatorial elites. However, that said, I mean, Sulla is in a bit of a bind because on the one hand, the whole reason he's done this is so that he can take his legions eastwards and and fight Mithridates and win a glorious war there. And so to do that, he knows that he needs
他们大多数人，我的意思是，他们不赞成苏拉的做法。但他们确实赞成苏拉所做的事情。参议院保守派非常不喜欢那种民粹主义者，如果你愿意的话。所以他们确实赞成苏拉基本上把马略赶出城市的措施。对他长期的怨恨，你知道，是长期的。他在参议院精英中非常、非常不受欢迎。然而，话虽如此，我的意思是，苏拉处于一种困境，因为一方面，他做这一切的全部原因是他可以带着他的军团向东，与米特里达梯作战，并在那里赢得一场光荣的战争。所以要做到这一点，他知道他需要
supporters in positions of power, and particularly he needs consuls in the following year 87, when he's going to be going off to the east. He needs supporters in position. Equally, if he imposes his own followers on the electorate, then that would make his claim to embody the rule of law completely ludicrous. He would be very nakedly a tyrant. And I think that really would provoke widespread popular opposition to him. So what Sulla does eventually is to settle for a compromise. So the consular elections are held. And Sulla's allies are defeated.
在权力职位上的支持者，特别是他需要在接下来的87年里有执政官，那时他将要去东方。他需要支持者在位。同样，如果他把自己的追随者强加给选民，那么这会使他声称体现法治的说法完全荒谬。他会非常赤裸裸地成为一个暴君。所以我认为这确实会引起广泛的民众反对他。所以苏拉最终做的是达成妥协。所以举行了执政官选举。苏拉的盟友被击败了。
And so he has to accept, as the two consuls that will be following him in 87, people who are hostile to what he's done. and one of these two men, a guy called Lucius Cornelius, Sinner, he had gone so far as to threaten Sulla with prosecution. So that's quite something for Sulla to swallow, but he does. However, he gets the two consuls, including Sinha, to come up with him onto the Capitol, which is the sacred hill, the hill of Jupiter, the great temple of Jupiter is on it. and he orders them to swear a public oath that they will not reverse his legislation. They will not stab him in the back. And Sinner and the other consul does so. And Sinner then spontaneously picks up a stone and throws it.
所以他不得不接受，作为将在87年跟随他的两名执政官，那些对他所做的事情怀有敌意的人。而这两个人中的一个，一个叫卢修斯·科尼利厄斯·辛纳的家伙，他甚至威胁要起诉苏拉。所以这对苏拉来说是相当大的吞咽，但他做到了。然而，他让包括辛纳在内的两名执政官和他一起登上卡皮托利诺山，这是神圣的山，朱庇特山，朱庇特的大神庙就在上面。他命令他们发公开誓言，他们不会推翻他的立法。他们不会在他背后捅刀子。辛纳和另一位执政官这样做了。然后辛纳自发地捡起一块石头扔了出去。
And he says, if I break my word, may I similarly be hurled out of Rome? You know, very flamboyant. Now, does Salah trust this? I mean, Sulla is a tremendous cynic. He's a brutal realist. I think almost certainly not. But the problem is that if he is to leave for the war against Mithridates in 87, he can't afford to hang around and make sure that everybody in Rome is absolutely trustworthy. And the whole while that Sala has been busy in the year of his consulship in 88, in the wake of
他说，如果我违背诺言，我是否也会被同样地赶出罗马？你知道，非常华丽。现在，苏拉相信这一点吗？我的意思是，苏拉是一个巨大的愤世嫉俗者。他是一个残酷的现实主义者。我想几乎肯定不是。但问题是，如果他要在87年离开去参加针对米特里达梯的战争，他负担不起徘徊并确保罗马的每个人都绝对值得信赖。而在苏拉在88年执政官任期内忙碌的整个过程中，在
his march on Rome, trying to sort things out in Italy, to make sure that it's going to be safe for him to leave Italy for the war against Mithridates. The situation in the East has been getting darker and darker. So the war in the East, or the situation in the East, this coming through the 80s is the greatest threat to Rome in a long time. I mean, we had the White Walkers in the previous episodes, but this guy is a king. He's very rich, isn't he? And he has ancient prophecies on his side.
他进军罗马之后，试图在意大利解决问题，以确保他离开意大利去参加针对米特里达梯的战争是安全的。东方的情况变得越来越黑暗。所以东方的战争，或者东方的情况，这进入80年代是罗马很长一段时间以来最大的威胁。我的意思是，我们在前几集里有异鬼，但这家伙是国王。他很有钱，不是吗？而且他有古老的预言站在他这一边。
So we love an ancient prophecy, and he's got loads of ancient prophecies on his side. Loads. They're all kinds of omens that have been current in the East for many decades. telling of how a great king is going to appear in the world, and he will come out of the East, and he will be an instrument of divine retribution against the overweening Roman superpower. And essentially, these prophecies have been bred of the kind of feeling of impotence and helplessness that most people in the Eastern Mediterranean have felt before the spectacle of Roman supremacy. And so Mithridates, who was actually dead to attack Rome, the first king to do so in over a century,
所以我们喜欢古老的预言，而且他有很多古老的预言站在他这一边。很多。几十年来，东方一直流传着各种预兆。讲述一位伟大的国王将如何出现在世界上，他将从东方出来，他将成为针对傲慢的罗马超级大国的神圣报应的工具。本质上，这些预言是由于大多数地中海东部人民在罗马至高无上的景象面前感到的那种无能和无助感而产生的。所以米特里达梯，他实际上是死于攻击罗马，一个多世纪以来第一个这样做的国王，
You know, he's very successful in invoking these prophecies and applying them to himself. But more than that, he has a tremendous eye for propaganda and a kind of striking image. So people may remember that the whole war against Mithridates had actually been provoked by a Roman ally of Marius, a guy called Mannyus Aquilius, who had kind of incited a neighboring king to invade Pontus's kingdom and it had all gone absolutely tits up. and Aquilius had ended up fleeing mainland Asia and kind of going out to an island just off the, just off the shore of Asia. And at a crucial point, he goes down with a stomach bug. And so when Mithridates agents arrive where he is in his sickbed, he is helpless to escape. And so he is captured.
你知道，他非常成功地援引这些预言并将它们应用到自己身上。但不仅如此，他有极好的宣传眼光和一种引人注目的形象。所以人们可能记得，针对米特里达梯的整场战争实际上是由马略的一位罗马盟友挑起的，一个叫曼尼乌斯·阿奎利乌斯的家伙，他曾煽动邻国国王入侵本都的王国，结果一切都完全搞砸了。阿奎利乌斯最终逃离了亚洲大陆，去了亚洲海岸外的一个岛屿。在关键时刻，他患上了胃病。所以当米特里达梯的特工到达他卧病在床的地方时，他无法逃脱。所以他被俘虏了。
And this offers such scope for a man as skillful at propaganda as Mithridates. So he has Aquilius chained to a seven-foot barbarian and dragged back from the coastline of Asia all the way to Pergamum, the capital of Asia. When they reach Pergamum, Aquilius is tied backwards onto an ass and paraded through the streets. And so everybody is able to vent their hatred of the Romans on him. And then finally, a very, very famous scene. Mithridates has gold melted down. and then Quillus is nostrils are held, his mouth is pulled open and that gold is poured down Aquilus's throat. And it's such a memorable gesture that people will claim that it's done to
这为像米特里达梯这样擅长宣传的人提供了很大的空间。所以他让阿奎利乌斯被锁在一个七英尺高的野蛮人身上，从亚洲海岸线一直拖回亚洲的首府帕加马。当他们到达帕加马时，阿奎利乌斯被背朝后绑在一头驴上，在街上游行。所以每个人都能向他发泄他们对罗马人的仇恨。然后最后，一个非常、非常著名的场景。米特里达梯让人把金子熔化。然后阿奎利乌斯的鼻孔被捏住，他的嘴被拉开，那金子被倒进阿奎利乌斯的喉咙里。这是一个如此令人难忘的姿态，以至于人们会声称它是为了
other Roman generals who fall prisoner of rebellious people in the East for many decades to come. Crasus. Isn't the something supposedly happened to Crasis? The story is told of Crasis as well. But I think this is the originator of the story. And Mithridates, you know, he proclaims to the people of Asia, why he has imposed this punishment on Aquilius. He says that it is an illustration of how the Romans have only one abiding motive, greed, deep-seated for empire and riches. And, you know, he's not wrong. The Romans have been absolute bloodsuckers when it comes to the poor cities of Asia. As a result of this, the other Greek cities in Asia, they've been simmering with a similar kind of resentment towards overweening Roman power.
在接下来的几十年里，其他落入东方叛乱人民手中的罗马将军。克拉苏。克拉苏身上不是也发生了类似的事情吗？关于克拉苏的故事也被讲述了。但我认为这是故事的起源。米特里达梯，你知道，他向亚洲人民宣告，为什么他要对阿奎利乌斯施加这种惩罚。他说，这是一个说明罗马人只有一个持久动机的例子，贪婪，对帝国和财富的根深蒂固的贪婪。而且，你知道，他没有错。当涉及到亚洲贫穷的城市时，罗马人绝对是吸血鬼。由于这个原因，亚洲的其他希腊城市，它们一直对傲慢的罗马权力怀有类似的怨恨。
upstart, this parveny from Italy that is trying to impose itself onto the Greek world, they pile in behind Mithridates, don't they? They're all, they're very up for this. They do, because Mithridates sends secret instructions to the leading figures in all the various cities of Asia, that they are to prepare a massacre of every Roman and Italian in Asia, most of whom belong to the business class that have been leaching onto the hapless Greeks. the Greeks in Asia could not be happier to join in. And when the massacre hits the Romans and the Italians, it hits them as a bolt from the blue. So they are completely without warning, as it seems to them. They're rounded up and they are slaughtered perhaps by hired assassins or
暴发户，这个来自意大利的暴发户，正试图将自己强加于希腊世界，他们都站在米特里达梯身后，不是吗？他们都非常支持这一点。他们确实支持，因为米特里达梯向亚洲所有各个城市的领导人物发送了秘密指示，他们要准备一场针对亚洲所有罗马人和意大利人的大屠杀，其中大多数属于一直寄生在不幸的希腊人身上的商业阶层。亚洲的希腊人非常乐意加入。当大屠杀袭击罗马人和意大利人时，它像晴天霹雳一样袭击了他们。所以他们完全没有预警，在他们看来。他们被围捕，然后被雇佣的刺客或
perhaps by vengeful mobs. Some of them are hacked to pieces as they cling to sacred statues or to altars. Others are shot as they attempt to swim out into the sea. And once they're dead, their bodies are then left to rot and buried outside the city walls of all the various cities that have participated in this massacre. And of course, the casualty figures are very inflated. So it said that 80,000 men, women and children were killed. But there's no question that these figures are believed back in Italy. And the impact on the Romans is kind of analogous perhaps to the impact that 9-11 had on Americans. It comes as a similar shock. The idea that the commanding high not just of their power, but of their economy,
也许被复仇的暴徒屠杀。有些人被砍成碎片，因为他们紧紧抓住神圣的雕像或祭坛。另一些人在试图游向大海时被射杀。一旦他们死了，他们的尸体就被留在那里腐烂，并被埋在所有参与这场大屠杀的各个城市的城墙外。当然，伤亡数字被严重夸大了。所以据说有80,000名男人、女人和儿童被杀。但毫无疑问，这些数字在意大利是被相信的。对罗马人的影响可能类似于9-11对美国人的影响。它带来了类似的冲击。认为他们权力的指挥高地，不仅是他们的权力，而且是他们的经济，
could be hit in this way, and so much bloodshed be inflicted comes as a complete surprise. But the difference with 9-11 is that Osama bin Laden did not then launch an invasion of Canada or something. But this is what Mithridis does, isn't it? Because you've already mentioned that he's eyeing up Greece. And he's now going to absolutely double down. He thinks Rome is vulnerable.
可能以这种方式受到打击，并造成如此多的流血事件，这完全是一个惊喜。但与9-11的区别在于，奥萨马·本·拉登随后并没有发动对加拿大的入侵之类的。但这就是米特里达梯所做的，不是吗？因为你已经提到他正在盯着希腊。他现在要绝对加倍下注。他认为罗马很脆弱。
And although Greece is not, I mean, Greece is not part of the Roman Empire, as it were, but it's part of the Roman sphere of influence at this point, presumably economically as well as diplomatically. Yeah, it's completely under the shadow of Roman power. Remember that the city of Corinth had been annihilated as evidence for the Greeks of what would happen if any Greek city chose to oppose the Romans. And so cities in Greece now are governed by pro-Roman oligarchs. And they do Rome's bidding and in return Rome rewards this class of collaborators. And the classic example of this is the most famous of all the Greek cities, and that is Athens. So Athens, by this point, it used to be an imperial power itself.
虽然希腊不是，我的意思是，希腊不是罗马帝国的一部分，但它在这一点上是罗马势力范围的一部分，大概在经济上和外交上也是如此。是的，它完全处于罗马权力的阴影之下。记住，科林斯城已经被摧毁，作为希腊人如果任何希腊城市选择反对罗马人会发生什么的证据。所以希腊的城市现在由亲罗马的寡头统治。他们听从罗马的命令，作为回报，罗马奖励这个合作者阶层。这方面的经典例子是所有希腊城市中最著名的一个，那就是雅典。所以雅典，在这一点上，它曾经是一个帝国强国本身。
That empire has long, long gone. It's democracy, to the degree that it still exists is a complete sham. It's independence. You know, it's nominal. It's nothing more really than a fig leaf. But if you are a millionaire, you know, with responsibility for running Athens, times a good. The Romans, you know, smile on you. They give you favourable treaties. They allow you to enjoy special trading relations with other parts of Rome's empire. And the plutocrats basically,
那个帝国早已不复存在。它的民主，在它仍然存在的程度上，是一个完全的骗局。它的独立。你知道，它是名义上的。它只不过是一片遮羞布。但如果你是一个百万富翁，你知道，有责任经营雅典，时代很好。罗马人，你知道，对你微笑。他们给你优惠的条约。他们允许你享受与罗马帝国其他部分特殊的贸易关系。而财阀基本上，
you know, they are happy to sell the rest of the Athenian people down the river in return for the power and wealth that backing Rome gives them. But obviously, the richer they get, the more the resentments of the mass of the people, the demos, as they are called, just and Fester. And so, unsurprisingly, when news of what has happened in Asia reaches Athens, everyone's completely gripped by this incredible spectacle. The collapse of Roman rule, the conquests of Mithridates, the massacre of so many Romans and Italians. And the business elite are obviously appalled, but the mass of people in Athens are, you know, they're thrilled. And this old longing for freedom, which has been repressed for so many years. But in Athens,
你知道，他们很乐意出卖雅典人民的其余部分，以换取支持罗马给他们的权力和财富。但显然，他们越富有，人民大众，也就是所谓的平民（demos），的怨恨就越发酵。所以，不出所料，当亚洲发生的事情的消息传到雅典时，每个人都被这种不可思议的景象完全吸引住了。罗马统治的崩溃，米特里达梯的征服，如此多罗马人和意大利人的大屠杀。商业精英显然感到震惊，但雅典的人民大众，你知道，他们很兴奋。这种对自由的古老渴望，已经被压抑了这么多年。但在雅典，
but in Athens is still felt as something living as part of the, you know, the historical patrimony of the Athenian people. It rouses the Demos, the Athenian people to dream that freedom might after all be theirs. And so a revolution breaks out. And it's led by a naturalized Athenian called Aristion. And inevitably, this being Athens, he is a philosopher. But just because he's a philosopher doesn't mean that he can't preside over a pogrom. And so he leads the mass of the people against the plut.
但在雅典仍然被视为一种活生生的东西，作为雅典人民历史遗产的一部分。它唤起了平民，雅典人民梦想着自由毕竟可能属于他们。所以一场革命爆发了。它由一个名叫阿里斯提翁的归化雅典人领导。不可避免地，既然是雅典，他是一位哲学家。但仅仅因为他是哲学家并不意味着他不能主持一场大屠杀。所以他带领人民大众对抗财阀。
Those who don't flee are massacred. And then he sends envoys to Mithridates on the other side of the Aegean saying, could we have an alliance? And Mithridates says, yeah, absolutely. This is brilliant. And he promptly sends an expeditionary force across the Aegean to Athens so that this alliance between Athens and the King of Pontus can be expressed in military terms. And of course, those military terms are targeted against Rome. And it seems with Athens now, allied to Mithridates, what is to stop other Greek cities from doing the same? And back in Italy, where Sulla has been watching the situation develop, not necessarily to Rome's advantage, he realizes that speed is an absolute premium now. You know, he has to get across the Adriatic,
那些没有逃跑的人被屠杀了。然后他派使者到爱琴海对岸的米特里达梯那里说，我们可以结盟吗？米特里达梯说，是的，绝对可以。这太棒了。他立即派遣了一支远征军穿过爱琴海前往雅典，以便雅典和本都国王之间的这种联盟可以用军事术语来表达。当然，这些军事术语是针对罗马的。随着雅典现在与米特里达梯结盟，似乎有什么能阻止其他希腊城市做同样的事情？而在意大利，苏拉一直在观察局势的发展，不一定是对罗马有利，他意识到速度现在是绝对的溢价。你知道，他必须穿过亚得里亚海，
get into Greece, see off Mithridates armies, because otherwise the whole of Greece and maybe Macedon as well, which is currently a Roman province, it might all just slip away. Tricky for Sulla though, isn't it? Because he's basically, I mean, he's got a lot of problems at once. He's got Marius on the loose. No one knows where Marius is or what he's going to get up to. He has one of the new consuls, Sinha. Sinner did that business with the stone. I'm not going to cause any trouble. I mean, one of the characteristics of very cynical, ruthless people is they assume that everybody else is as cynical and ruthless as they are. So Sulla can't trust Sina. One thing we haven't really talked about actually, you know, Sulla was involved in this war against the Italian, the rest of Italy. the social war. That's still going on, isn't it? And actually nobody really has decided, I mean, there's still a massive political argument about how to end that particular war. I mean, almost everybody thinks that the Italians should be given the vote and they should, you know, they should be incorporated fully into the Roman Republic, but exactly how is still a moot point. So Sulla is taking a big risk by leaving all this behind, unresolved, to go over to,
进入希腊，击退米特里达梯的军队，因为否则整个希腊，甚至可能包括目前作为罗马行省的马其顿，都可能彻底失守。这对苏拉来说很棘手，不是吗？因为他基本上，我是说，他同时面临很多问题。马略逍遥法外。没人知道马略在哪里，或者他打算做什么。他有其中一位新执政官，秦纳。秦纳做了那件关于石头的事。我不会惹任何麻烦。我是说，非常愤世嫉俗、冷酷无情的人的一个特点是，他们认为其他人也和他们一样愤世嫉俗、冷酷无情。所以苏拉不能信任秦纳。其实有一件事我们还没真正谈过，你知道，苏拉参与了这场针对意大利人、针对意大利其余地区的战争，即同盟战争。那场战争还在继续，不是吗？实际上没人真正决定，我是说，关于如何结束那场特定的战争，仍然存在巨大的政治争论。我是说，几乎所有人都认为应该给予意大利人投票权，他们应该，你知道，他们应该被完全纳入罗马共和国，但具体如何做仍然是一个悬而未决的问题。所以苏拉冒着巨大的风险，把这一切留在这里，未解决，就去往，
Greece and presumably to Asia. But I guess does he think he has no choice that this is existential for Rome? I think it's probably less Rome than him. He, you know, he has marched on Rome. He has dared very greatly in the course of ensuring that he can lead this war against Smithredeatis. So he has to go. But you're right that in every sense, if he crosses the Adriatic and leaves Italy behind, there is no guarantee that he will remain legally a general of the Roman Republic. It's very likely that his enemies will secure power and if they do, then they will name him an enemy of the state. So it is a huge gamble. And I think that for that reason, before he leaves, he makes one attempt to provide some military security for himself in Italy while he is away.
希腊，大概还有亚洲。但我猜他在想他别无选择，这对罗马来说是生死攸关的吗？我认为这可能对他个人而言比对罗马更重要。他，你知道，他进军了罗马。为了确保自己能领导这场针对米特里达梯的战争，他冒了极大的风险。所以他必须去。但你是对的，从任何意义上讲，如果他跨过亚得里亚海，把意大利抛在身后，没有任何保证他能合法地继续担任罗马共和国的将军。他的敌人很有可能夺取政权，如果他们这样做了，他们就会宣布他为国家公敌。所以这是一场巨大的赌博。我认为正是因为这个原因，在他离开之前，他试图在离开期间为自己在意大利提供一些军事保障。
So in the dying days of his consulship, he'd been consul with this guy, Pompeius Rufus, who had been beaten up by Maris's thugs before Sulla's march on Rome and stripped of his consulship. And Sulla, when he marches on Rome, he has this colleague, this friend of his, this associate, Pompeius Rufus, reinstalled as a consul. And because Pompeius Rufus can absolutely be relied upon, what Sulla really wants is for him to have a great army of legions so that he will, you know, he will. be a heavyweight to his other enemies in Roman Italy. So he thinks there is this guy Strabo in Pisinum, which is the area on the kind of the central Italy on the Adriatic coast. And Strabo,
所以在他执政官任期的最后几天，他曾与这个叫庞培·鲁弗斯的人共同担任执政官，此人在苏拉进军罗马之前被马略的暴徒殴打，并被剥夺了执政官职位。而苏拉在进军罗马时，让他的这位同事、朋友、伙伴庞培·鲁弗斯官复原职。因为庞培·鲁弗斯绝对值得信赖，苏拉真正想要的是让他拥有一支强大的军团，这样他就能，你知道，他能成为对抗他在罗马意大利的其他敌人的重量级人物。所以他认为在皮塞努姆有这个叫斯特拉博的人，那是意大利中部亚得里亚海沿岸的地区。而斯特拉博，
people may remember. Strabo means squint. Strabo has it's a nickname. He's a very sinister figure, but very effective. And he has been laying siege to the city of Asculum where the social war had originally broken out. He's done a very good job. He storms it. He storms it. he's basically crushed the revolution, the rebellion, the social war in central Italy. But Sulla's wheeze is to say, well, if the war is over, then Strabo doesn't need his legions anymore. So as consul, I will force through a bill saying that Strabo should hand over his legions to Pompeius Rufus, and then my ally will have the legions. And of course, this is exactly basically what Marius has done.
人们可能还记得。斯特拉博的意思是斜视。斯特拉博是一个绰号。他是一个非常阴险的人物，但非常有效率。他一直在围攻阿斯库卢姆城，同盟战争最初就是从那里爆发的。他做得非常好。他强攻了它。他强攻了它。他基本上粉碎了意大利中部的革命、叛乱、同盟战争。但苏拉的诡计是说，好吧，如果战争结束了，那么斯特拉博就不再需要他的军团了。所以作为执政官，我将强行通过一项法案，说斯特拉博应该把他的军团移交给庞培·鲁弗斯，然后我的盟友就会拥有这些军团。当然，这基本上正是马略所做的事情。
Yeah, does it not occur to Sulla that actually Pompeius Rufus, when he arrives, Strabo might say, no, I'm going to keep the legions myself, just as Sulla had done him, you know, in his turn. I think this is what's so interesting. You were saying, you know, it does it? How unthinkable is it for people to do what Sulla has done? I think it's so unthinkable that even Sulla thinks that no one else will do it. That's the measure of how kind of fateful a step his march on Rome was.
是的，苏拉难道没想过，实际上当庞培·鲁弗斯到达时，斯特拉博可能会说，不，我要自己保留这些军团，就像苏拉轮到他时所做的那样吗？我认为这正是最有趣的地方。你刚才说，你知道，是吗？人们做苏拉所做的事是多么不可想象？我认为这太不可想象了，以至于连苏拉都认为没有其他人会这样做。这就是他进军罗马这一步是多么宿命的衡量标准。
So as you say, what is to stop Strabo doing to Pompeis Rufus, what Sulla had done to Marius's ambassadors? Well, Pompeius Rufus turns up and Strabo greets him with a kind of very menacing politeness. And then he says, I'm afraid I can't hang around here. I'm called away on urgent business. I'll be away for the next couple of days. But do as you will, do take over my legions. So the next day, Pompeius Rufus gathers all the soldiers around him and he celebrates his
所以正如你所说，有什么能阻止斯特拉博对庞培·鲁弗斯做苏拉对马略的使者所做的事呢？好吧，庞培·鲁弗斯出现了，斯特拉博以一种非常具有威胁性的礼貌迎接了他。然后他说，恐怕我不能在这里逗留。我有紧急事务要处理。接下来的几天我都不在。但随你的便吧，接管我的军团吧。所以第二天，庞培·鲁弗斯把所有的士兵召集在他周围，他以传统方式庆祝他的
command in the traditional manner by performing a sacrifice. And as he is conducting the sacrifice, a gang of Strabo's soldiers, start to push in on him. And as he raises the sacrificial knife to kill the victim that's being sacrificed, these soldiers seize him and they strike him down. And a Roman scholar later described it, he perished as though he were the sacrificial offering himself. The Strabo comes back and he says, I'm shocked, shocked to discover what's happened.
指挥权，即举行祭祀。当他进行祭祀时，一群斯特拉博的士兵开始挤向他。当他举起祭祀刀准备杀死祭品时，这些士兵抓住了他，并将他击倒。一位罗马学者后来描述道，他死得就像他自己就是祭品一样。斯特拉博回来后说，我感到震惊，震惊于发现发生了什么事。
But he takes no action against the mutineers and the legions remain securely under his command. And so Sulla does not have that body of legions backing him that he had hoped for. Question about Strabo. Is Strabo at this point loyal to Marius as he operating in his own? He's his own man. He's his own man. So isn't that a sign of how generally, structurally, Roman politics and Roman kind of military politics is kind of breaking down? Because you describe Strabo as a warlord.
但他没有对哗变者采取任何行动，军团仍然牢牢地在他的指挥之下。所以苏拉并没有得到他所希望的那支军团的支持。关于斯特拉博的问题。斯特拉博此时效忠于马略吗？还是他在为自己行事？他是他自己的人。他是他自己的人。那么这难道不是罗马政治和罗马军事政治在结构上正在崩溃的迹象吗？因为你把斯特拉博描述为一个军阀。
I mean, this is not just a general as part of an institution. This is an independent military power broker, kingmaker, in different circumstances, I guess. Yeah, and I think that's exactly what Strabo is doing, is waiting to see who's going to win, but keeping his legions close to him. And so this is a really malign situation in Italy, but it is one that Sulla, sighs, well, what the hell, I'm off. He gets in his ships, he loads his men up, they cross the Adriatic, he lands on the far side, and he is going to war in the east. We'll find out what happens in the East. And indeed, what on earth has happened to our protagonist, Gaius Marius, after the break. Hello, this is Tom Holland from Goalhangers.
我是说，这不仅仅是一个作为机构一部分的将军。这是一个独立的军事权力掮客，在不同情况下，我想是造王者。是的，我认为这正是斯特拉博正在做的，他在等待看谁会赢，但把他的军团紧紧地控制在自己手中。所以这是意大利一个非常恶劣的局面，但苏拉叹了口气，管他呢，我走了。他上了船，让部下登船，他们穿过亚得里亚海，他在对岸登陆，他要去东方打仗。我们会在休息后找出东方发生了什么。当然，我们的主角盖乌斯·马略到底发生了什么。你好，我是来自Goalhangers的汤姆·霍兰德。
The Rest is History. And I'm James Holland from Gollhangers. We have ways of making you talk. We're here to introduce pressure. An unmissable World War II drama from the producers of Darkest Hour, now hitting the big screen. It tells the gripping, yet I think widely unknown story of a meteorologist called James Stagg, who played an absolutely crucial role in the launching of D-Day. Well, yes, because May had been a beautiful month for the beginning of June was gorgeous weather too,
《历史的其余部分》。我是来自Gollhangers的詹姆斯·霍兰德。我们有办法让你开口。我们在这里介绍《压力》。一部来自《至暗时刻》制片人的不可错过的二战剧情片，现在正在大银幕上映。它讲述了一个名叫詹姆斯·斯塔格的气象学家的扣人心弦但我想广为人知的故事，他在诺曼底登陆的启动中发挥了绝对关键的作用。嗯，是的，因为五月对于六月初来说是一个美丽的月份，天气也很棒，
and then suddenly it turned and huge storms were approaching, fast approaching from across the Atlantic, threatening to completely wreck the whole D-Day invasion. Yeah, it's an amazing film. It stars Andrew Scott as Stag, Brendan Fraser as Eisenhower and Damien Lewis as Montgomery. Pressure is an absolute must-see. Pressure is exclusively in cinemas from September the 9th. In Toronto, every arrival is a statement, and nothing says it better than this. Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025. Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19 speaker AKG surround audio. system. This city demands agility and optic delivers with precision to make every drive extraordinary. Let's take the Cadillac. Find out more at Cadillac Canada.ca. Luxury sales claim based on S&P Global Mobility Canadian New Vehicle Total Registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury.
然后突然天气变了，巨大的风暴从大西洋彼岸迅速逼近，威胁要彻底摧毁整个诺曼底登陆入侵。是的，这是一部了不起的电影。由安德鲁·斯科特饰演斯塔格，布兰登·费舍饰演艾森豪威尔，达米安·刘易斯饰演蒙哥马利。《压力》绝对是必看之作。《压力》将于9月9日起在影院独家上映。在多伦多，每一次抵达都是一种宣言，没有什么比这更能说明问题了。凯迪拉克Optiq是2025年加拿大销量第一的豪华电动汽车。在无缝的33英寸显示屏和沉浸式的19扬声器AKG环绕音响系统中找到你的节奏。这座城市需要敏捷，而Optiq以精准交付，让每一次驾驶都非同寻常。让我们选择凯迪拉克。在CadillacCanada.ca了解更多信息。豪华销售声明基于标普全球移动公司2025日历年凯迪拉克豪华定义下的加拿大新车总注册量。
So welcome back to the rest of history. The year is 87 BC. It's all looking very febrile in the east, but also in Rome. And just before the break, we were wanting to be. wondering what had happened to the protagonist of this entire series, Gaius Marius. Well, Tom, what has happened to Marius? So he fled Rome. What has become of him since? He's in a real bind because he's been declared a public enemy. Sulla has leaned on the cellet to have that bill passed.
欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是公元前87年。东方看起来非常狂热，罗马也是如此。就在休息之前，我们想知道整个系列的主角盖乌斯·马略发生了什么。那么，汤姆，马略发生了什么？所以他逃离了罗马。此后他变得怎样了？他陷入了真正的困境，因为他被宣布为公敌。苏拉向元老院施压，通过了那项法案。
And so he is now an outlaw. And on top of that, as you were saying, he's very old. He's very fat. And he has one of the most recognizable faces in the whole of Rome. So basically, you know, what is a 69-year-old overweight six-time consul to do? There's only one thing he can really do, and that is to go undercover. And so this is what Marius does. And he takes refuge on one of the many estates he has outside Rome, and he's hidden in a cartload of beans.
所以他现在是一个逃犯。最重要的是，正如你所说，他非常老。他非常胖。而且他拥有罗马最容易辨认的面孔之一。所以基本上，你知道，一个69岁、超重的六次执政官该怎么办？他唯一能做的就是潜伏起来。所以这就是马略所做的。他在罗马城外他拥有的众多庄园之一避难，并藏在一车豆子里。
And hidden by the beans, he is then taken by a loyal carter down to Ostia, which is the port of Rome. And from there he takes ship to Africa. And Africa is the obvious place he would go, because that is where he had won his first great military victories. He has lots of allies and supporters there. But complete disaster. There's a storm. And Marius and his companions get driven ashore. And from that point on, it is a non-stop catalogue of scrapes and near misses. So they escape squads who've come to arrest them by the skin of their teeth. They hitch lift, with passing merchants who then decide that they don't want to have anything to do with him and dump him on the shore.
藏在豆子里，他随后被一名忠诚的马车夫带到奥斯蒂亚，那是罗马的港口。从那里他乘船前往非洲。非洲是他显然会去的地方，因为那是他赢得第一次伟大军事胜利的地方。他在那里有很多盟友和支持者。但完全是一场灾难。有一场风暴。马略和他的同伴被冲上岸。从那时起，这就是一连串不断的困境和险些被捕的经历。他们千钧一发地逃脱了前来逮捕他们的分队。他们搭乘过往商人的顺风车，但商人随后决定不想与他有任何瓜葛，就把他扔在岸上。
There's one particularly hairy incident where Marius ends up hiding naked in a marsh, kind of burying himself in mud. So I always kind of think of it. It's like Marlon Brando in the mud. Colonel Kurtz. Colonel Kurtz, yeah. What is it? You're an errand boy.
有一个特别惊险的事件，马略最终赤身裸体地躲在沼泽里，把自己埋在泥里。所以我总是这样想。就像马龙·白兰度在泥里一样。库尔茨上校。库尔茨上校，是的。那是什么？你是个跑腿的。
Yeah. It's that moment. But unfortunately, he is discovered and he's hauled out from the all covered in the gunk of the swamp and he gets locked up in a cell and the local kind of town council think well we now we've taken him we better get rid of him but they're all very nervous so they think well let's get a paid assassin to do it and they fix on a kimbrian so one of those barbarians who'd been defeated ironically by marius like a dane yeah so lots and lots of had been taken as slaves and this is presumably a slave and they give this kimbrian a sword and say go in and
是的。就是那一刻。但不幸的是，他被发现了，他被从沼泽的污垢中拖了出来，被关进了一个牢房，当地的市议会想，好吧，既然我们抓住了他，我们最好除掉他，但他们都很紧张，所以他们想，好吧，让我们雇一个职业杀手来做这件事，他们选中了一个辛布里人，也就是那些被马略讽刺地击败的野蛮人之一，就像丹麦人一样，是的，所以很多很多人被当作奴隶抓走了，这大概是一个奴隶，他们给了这个辛布里人一把剑，说进去，
finish off Marius. So he goes into the cell. It's very dark and all the Kimbrian can see is the kind of, I like to imagine, red glare of his eyes, kind of staring at him from the shadows. And then he hears Marius's voice, man, do you dare to kill Gaius Marius? And the Kimbrian does not dare. He's absolutely terrified. Oh my word. His Martin Sheen runs away. Yeah, he runs out of the cell, wailing, I cannot kill Gaius Marius. He is, you know, this, this, this, guy is just too terrifying. And the local authorities, they decide that, you know, they can't kill him either. Marius is the, you know, he's the great savior of Rome. He's such an impressive man. They don't want to just dispatch him. So what they do is they give him back his clothes and they put him on a
干掉马略。所以他走进牢房。里面很黑，辛布里人能看到的只有，我喜欢想象，他眼中闪烁的红光，从阴影中盯着他。然后他听到了马略的声音，人啊，你敢杀盖乌斯·马略吗？辛布里人不敢。他绝对吓坏了。天哪。他的马丁·辛跑开了。是的，他跑出牢房，哀嚎着，我不能杀盖乌斯·马略。他，你知道，这个，这个，家伙太可怕了。当地当局决定，你知道，他们也不能杀他。马略是，你知道，他是罗马的伟大救星。他是一个如此令人印象深刻的人。他们不想就这样处决他。所以他们做的是把衣服还给他，并把他放在一艘
boat and they say, just, you know, get out of here. We don't have anything else to do with you. And so this enables Marius to cross from Italy to Africa and he makes land by where Carthage had stood. So these ivy-clad ruins absolutely deserted. And the governor of Africa sends him a message saying, if you stay here, then I will uphold the decrees of the Senate and treat you as a public enemy. So I'm giving you a chance to get out. And Marius groans, and then he gives a very famous answer.
船上，他们说，只是，你知道，离开这里吧。我们和你没什么别的可做的了。所以这使马略能够从意大利跨越到非洲，他在迦太基曾经矗立的地方登陆。所以这些常春藤覆盖的废墟完全荒无人烟。非洲总督给他发了一条信息说，如果你留在这里，那么我将维护元老院的法令，把你当作公敌。所以我给你一个离开的机会。马略呻吟着，然后他给出了一个非常著名的回答。
It's very celebrated in later Roman history. Tell the governor that you have seen, Gaius, a fugitive, sitting among the room. ruins of Carthage. I mean, you're doing it with an American accent, but I just think this is made for Russell Crow, especially Russell Crow now. No, it's Malam Brando.
这在后来的罗马历史上非常有名。告诉总督，你已经看到了盖乌斯，一个逃犯，坐在迦太基的废墟中。我是说，你用美国口音说出来，但我只是觉得这简直是为罗素·克劳量身定做的，尤其是现在的罗素·克劳。不，是马龙·白兰度。
When he's a little bit heavier, you know, he's somebody, people associate with Rome. I mean, this is absolutely made for him. Yeah, who do you have a seller? A young Jude Law is basically ideal for seller, but he's too old now. No, I think Jude Law, Jude Law would be good.
当他稍微胖一点的时候，你知道，他是一个人们与罗马联系在一起的人。我是说，这绝对是为他准备的。是的，你觉得苏拉是谁？年轻的裘德·洛基本上是苏拉的理想人选，但他现在太老了。不，我认为裘德·洛，裘德·洛会很不错。
Although Tom Holland, I've always had Tom Holland in mind for Octavian, by the way. I think he'd be a brilliant Octavian. I think you're right about that. But yeah, okay, well, let's say Garret, Gaius Marius, from this point I will give him an Australian accent. So is it all over for Marius? He's stuck in Carthage. He's got no arms.
虽然汤姆·霍兰德，顺便说一句，我一直把汤姆·霍兰德视为屋大维的人选。我认为他会是一个出色的屋大维。我想你是对的。但好吧，好吧，让我们说盖乌斯·马略，从这一点开始，我会给他一个澳大利亚口音。所以马略的一切都结束了吗？他被困在迦太基。他没有武器。
He's got no backing. He's being disrespected by the local governor. It's not all over for him, actually, because remember that prophecy, which had decreed that he would end up holding seven consulships. Fate will not be denied. And you are right, Dominic, because back in Italy, circumstances are becoming. more favourable for Marius. So by this point, Sulla has left for the war with Mithridates, and the two new consuls have embarked on their magistracies. So one of these two consuls we've already mentioned, this is Sinha. And we've said, he hates Sulla. And he has solemnly and publicly
他没有支持。他受到当地总督的不尊重。其实并没有结束，因为记住那个预言，它规定他最终将担任七次执政官。命运不可违。你是对的，多米尼克，因为在意大利，情况对马略变得更有利了。所以到这个时候，苏拉已经离开去打米特里达梯战争了，两位新执政官已经开始了他们的任期。所以这两位执政官中的一位我们已经提到了，这就是秦纳。我们说过，他讨厌苏拉。而且他已经庄严且公开地
sworn an oath on the capital not to reverse Sulla's legislation, but we've been asking all along, can he be trusted? Sinner is a very, very slippery customer. His colleague, a guy called Nias Octavius, he's not a fan of Sulla. either, but he is the kind of man who probably can be trusted to keep an oath because he is old school. He's a classic conservative. He's the kind of person who once he's sworn an oath to the gods is liable to keep it. Clearly, Sinna and Octavius are very different calibre of men, and it doesn't take long for them to fall out, and they fall out over this kind of perennial bugbear of Roman politics by this point, which is the question of how far the Italians should
在卡皮托利诺山上宣誓不推翻苏拉的立法，但我们一直都在问，他值得信任吗？秦纳是一个非常、非常滑头的人。他的同事，一个叫尼阿斯·屋大维的人，他也不是苏拉的粉丝。但他是一个可能值得信任去遵守誓言的人，因为他是老派的。他是一个典型的保守派。他是一个一旦向神灵宣誓就倾向于遵守的人。显然，秦纳和屋大维是截然不同的人，他们没过多久就闹翻了，他们因为罗马政治中这个长期存在的难题而闹翻，那就是意大利人应该在多大程度上
be given full enfranchisement, full Roman citizenship. And under the under the normal circumstances, these kind of disagreements would have been contained within the Senate House. But as we've been saying, the climate in Rome has becoming ever more violent. Politics is being militarised. And so arguments that begin in the Senate have a tendency now to escalate. And it doesn't take long for the disagreements between Sinner and Octavius to get very badly out of control. And it ends up with Sinner being expelled by. Octavius, officially stripped of his consulship by the Senate, and once again proclaimed a public enemy. So essentially now, what has happened in Rome is that every time there's a disagreement
获得完全的选举权，完全的罗马公民权。在正常情况下，这些分歧会被限制在元老院内。但正如我们所说，罗马的气候变得越来越暴力。政治正在军事化。所以始于元老院的争论现在有升级的趋势。秦纳和屋大维之间的分歧没过多久就变得完全失控了。最终导致秦纳被屋大维驱逐，被元老院正式剥夺了执政官职位，并再次被宣布为公敌。所以基本上现在，罗马发生的事情是，每次有分歧
between the consuls, it ends with one of the consuls being decreed an outlaw. And this does not make for a healthy politics. It does not at all. And how much is that a break with established Roman politics? Massively. So actually, this is a really good for democracies that may have modelled themselves on Rome and are obsessed with not following the example of Rome. this is a really good example in the dangers of excessive polarization and everything becoming political disagreements being litigated in the courts and painting your opponents as the enemies of the republic.
在执政官之间，最终结果都是其中一位执政官被宣布为逃犯。这并不能造就健康的政治。一点也不。这在多大程度上是对既定罗马政治的背离？非常大。所以实际上，这对那些可能以罗马为榜样并痴迷于不重蹈罗马覆辙的民主国家来说，这是一个关于过度两极分化危险的很好的例子，一切都变成了政治分歧在法庭上进行诉讼，并将你的对手描绘成共和国的敌人。
Isn't it? I mean, this is what happens. Yes, because if you use very violent rhetoric, that violent rhetoric can become real and once it becomes real, then essentially you've let a very dangerous genie out of a bottle. And this is essentially what has happened. So there's basically no space left for pluralism. I mean, insofar as there was a limited amount of pluralism, differences of opinion, reasonable differences opinion. The idea that every citizen has freedom of speech is really important in the Republic.
不是吗？我是说，这就是发生的事情。是的，因为如果你使用非常暴力的言辞，那种暴力的言辞就会变成现实，一旦它变成现实，那么基本上你就放出了一个非常危险的精灵。这基本上就是发生的事情。所以基本上没有留下多元主义的空间。我是说，就存在有限的多元主义而言，意见分歧，合理的意见分歧。每个公民都有言论自由的想法在共和国中真的很重要。
And it's upheld. People can basically say what they like. This is why even those who are not in the Senate are so ready to scraw graffiti insulting their enemies across the city. It's taken for granted that this is the right of people living in a free state. But if you are going to end up killed or declared a public enemy every time you have a disagreement with one of your peers, then it becomes incredibly dangerous. Octavius has taken this step. So Sinna now does exactly the same. And he does a Sulla.
而且它得到了维护。人们基本上可以畅所欲言。这就是为什么即使是那些不在元老院的人也如此乐于在城市各处涂鸦侮辱他们的敌人。人们认为这是生活在自由国家的人民的权利。但如果你每次与同僚有分歧时最终都会被杀或被宣布为公敌，那么这就变得极其危险。屋大维采取了这一步。所以秦纳现在做了完全一样的事。他做了一个苏拉。
He goes to Nola where this siege is still dragging on. And he works his magic on the legionaries who are camped out beside the city, that one legion that had been left behind to prosecute the siege. And then he gets that legion on side. and then he goes on a tour of various cities around Italy, recruiting more men, raising cash, and he then takes a fateful step. He sends a messenger to Piscinum on the east coast of Italy, where Strabo is camped out with all his legions. And so Strabo then duly crosses the Apennines from Pysenum, and he makes camp outside Rome beside the Colleen Gate, which is the gate in the north of the walls.
他去了诺拉，那里的围攻仍在拖延。他对驻扎在城市旁边的军团士兵施展了他的魔力，那是唯一一支被留下来进行围攻的军团。然后他让那支军团站在他这一边，然后他在意大利各地的城市巡回，招募更多的人，筹集现金，然后他采取了一个决定性的步骤。他派了一名信使到意大利东海岸的皮塞努姆，斯特拉博带着他所有的军团驻扎在那里。所以斯特拉博随后如期穿过皮塞努姆的亚平宁山脉，他在罗马城墙北侧的科林门旁扎营，
of Rome, and he's obviously a very menacing presence. This very sinister operator with all these legions camped outside one of the main gates of your city. And what makes it all the more ominous is that actually he hasn't come out on Sinner's side. He hasn't come out on Octavis' side. He's clearly waiting to see which of these two consuls is going to need him the most and then demand his price. One man, however, has by this point swung fully behind Sinner, and that is Marius. So Marius has, you know, he gets the news that Sinner is on the loose. He crosses from Africa with his son and with assorted henchmen and he then uses the magic of his name to recruit a private army himself, lots of escape slaves, lots of old soldiers,
罗马，他显然是一个非常有威胁的存在。这个非常阴险的操作者带着所有这些军团驻扎在你们城市的主要城门外。更不祥的是，实际上他并没有站在秦纳一边。他也没有站在屋大维一边。他显然在等待看这两位执政官中谁最需要他，然后索要他的代价。然而，有一个人此时已经完全转向支持秦纳，那就是马略。所以马略，你知道，他得到消息说秦纳逍遥法外。他带着他的儿子和随从从非洲跨越过来，然后他利用他名字的魔力招募了一支私人军队，很多逃跑的奴隶，很多老兵，
people like that, rallying to, you know, the old man, the magic of his name. And so Sinner is nervous of Marius. basically by this point everyone is nervous of Marius because he is he's completely wired. I mean, he's he's really ready to kill anybody who annoys him by this point. He's very, very Colonel Kurtz, I think by now. Right. So you think Marius has, well, is 69, he probably doesn't have that much longer to live, or something has flipped in his head or what is it?
诸如此类的人，聚集到，你知道，这位老人身边，他名字的魔力。所以秦纳对马略感到紧张。基本上到这个时候每个人都对马略感到紧张，因为他完全疯了。我是说，他真的准备好杀掉任何此时惹恼他的人。他非常、非常像库尔茨上校，我想现在。对。所以你认为马略有，嗯，是69岁，他可能活不了多久了，或者他的脑子里有什么东西翻转了，还是什么？
I think there's kind of a, it's like King Lear thing that he's so stupefied by, you know, the collapse of all his fortunes that something's gone inside his head. he is much more murderous, much more headstrong than he had ever been before. But Sinha thinks, well, it's better to have Marius on your side than against you. So they team up and they advance on Rome and they put the city under siege. And at one point they actually managed to break in through the walls. But at this point, Strabo clearly thinks, I don't really want Marius inside Rome. So he comes to Octavius's help and the men of Sina and Marius are flung back out.
我想这有点像李尔王的事情，他被，你知道，他所有财富的崩溃弄得目瞪口呆，以至于他的脑子里发生了什么变化。他比以前任何时候都更嗜杀，更固执。但秦纳想，好吧，让马略站在你这边总比站在对立面好。所以他们联手向罗马推进，并对城市进行了围攻。有一次他们实际上设法冲破了城墙。但在这一点上，斯特拉博显然认为，我真的不想让马略进入罗马。所以他来帮助屋大维，秦纳和马略的人被赶了出去。
And so the stasis between these three books. blocks of men. Octavius in Rome, Strabo in his camp outside the Colleen Gate, Marius and Sinner with their men. It's kind of this very kind of uneasy tension there. And then suddenly it becomes clear that all along the gods have had Marius's back because at this point, a grotesque series of disasters intervene on Marius's behalf. So Strabo's camp is abruptly swept by plague and he catches it himself and retires to bed. The tent is then struck by lightning and Strabo is incinerated. He's, what, by the lightning?
所以这三块人马之间的僵局。屋大维在罗马，斯特拉博在他科林门外的营地，马略和秦纳带着他们的人。那里有一种非常不安的紧张气氛。然后突然变得很清楚，一直以来神灵都站在马略这边，因为在这一点上，一系列怪诞的灾难代表马略发生了。所以斯特拉博的营地突然被瘟疫席卷，他自己也染上了，并卧床不起。帐篷随后被闪电击中，斯特拉博被烧焦了。他，什么，被闪电？
By the lightning. So he's got plague, then he gets hit by lightning. I mean, it's a really bad day at the office. What are the chances of that happening? That just seems mad. Very low. And then his funeral procession is held, and he's so unpopular that the crowd sees his ashes.
被闪电。所以他得了瘟疫，然后又被闪电击中。我是说，这真是糟糕透顶的一天。发生这种情况的几率是多少？这看起来太疯狂了。非常低。然后举行了他的葬礼，他太不受欢迎了，以至于人群看到了他的骨灰。
And it's only the intervention of a tribune that prevents them from being desecrated. And he leaves behind this very dark reputation, the art trimmer. But he also leaves behind a young son, only 19 years old. Pompeius, Pompey, as he's better known. And this is someone of whom we will be hearing more later in this series. Pompey, the great sense of the story. He has. So exciting.
只有一位保民官的干预才阻止了它们被亵渎。他留下了一个非常黑暗的名声，那个修剪者。但他还留下了一个年轻的儿子，只有19岁。庞培，也就是大家更熟悉的庞培。这是我们稍后在这个系列中会听到更多关于他的人。庞培，故事的伟大意义。他有。太令人兴奋了。
But at this point, he's only 19 years old. He hasn't really made a name for himself yet. but he will be making a name for himself very soon. I'm so pumped he's back in the story. All right, so let's pull the camera back a bit. Strabo is dead. Sinra and Marius have absolutely the upper hand, and presumably now they can just waltz into Rome.
但在这一点上，他只有19岁。他还没有真正成名。但他很快就会成名。我很高兴他回到了故事中。好吧，让我们把镜头拉远一点。斯特拉博死了。秦纳和马略绝对占了上风，大概现在他们可以大摇大摆地走进罗马了。
Yeah, there's no one to stop them. And do they behave with decorum, elegance and grace? They absolutely do not. Octavius, the consul, refuses to flee. Instead, he sits in his chair of office, and this is where he's surprised by Maris's men who chop him up into little pieces. Marius, by this stage, has gone completely psychotic. His bitterness and rage, you know, this is all that he is. He's an absolute monster. And he is out
是的，没有人能阻止他们。他们表现得庄重、优雅和得体吗？他们绝对没有。执政官屋大维拒绝逃跑。相反，他坐在他的办公椅上，这就是他被马略的人袭击的地方，他们把他剁成了碎片。马略在这个阶段已经完全精神错乱了。他的痛苦和愤怒，你知道，这就是他的全部。他是一个绝对的怪物。而且他
to get everyone whom he holds to blame for his recent misadventures. And some are murdered by his gangs of slaves. Others are targeted for prosecution. And meanwhile, Dominic, you've been poo-pooing this prophecy the whole way through the series. But you are going to have to eat your words because at this point, Marius is elected to his seventh consulship, the record-breaking consulship. So that proves it. Wow. I'm like Wayne Rooney having to row down the Hudson, which he did, if you recall, because he made a foolish prophecy during the World Cup that Norway wouldn't reach the quarterfinals. I mean, it would be great to see you rowing down a river.
要对所有他认为应该为他最近的不幸负责的人下手。有些人被他的奴隶团伙谋杀。其他人则成为起诉的目标。与此同时，多米尼克，你在这个系列中一直对这个预言嗤之以鼻。但你将不得不收回你的话，因为在这一点上，马略当选为他的第七次执政官，破纪录的执政官任期。所以这证明了这一点。哇。我就像韦恩·鲁尼不得不划船下哈德逊河一样，如果你还记得的话，他确实这样做了，因为他在世界杯期间做了一个愚蠢的预言，说挪威不会进入四分之一决赛。我是说，看到你划船下河会很棒。
Well, that Wayne Rooney comparison has dogged me for so long. I'm happy to lean into it once again. Do you know who Maris reminds me of at this point? So it's Colonel Kurtz melded with DeNaris Targaryen. Yes. Yes. He's a fat 69-year-old Deneres Targaryen. Probably too heavy for a dragon.
好吧，那个韦恩·鲁尼的比较困扰了我很久。我很高兴再次倾向于它。你知道马略在这一点上让我想起了谁吗？所以是库尔茨上校与丹妮莉丝·坦格利安的结合。是的。是的。他是一个69岁的胖丹妮莉丝·坦格利安。可能太重了，骑不了龙。
He's gone mad. He's like coarsened by resentment and victimhoods and he's killing everybody. Yeah. All his men are out slaughtering everybody. Maris himself goes on a massive bender. He abandons himself completely to viable. silent drinking bouts and when he's not drunk and he's asleep, he's suffering terrible nightmares. And two weeks after he has been elected to his seventh consulship, he dies.
他疯了。他就像被怨恨和受害者心态弄得粗鲁，他在杀所有人。是的。他所有的人都在屠杀所有人。马略自己开始狂欢。他完全沉溺于恶毒的、沉默的饮酒狂欢中，当他不喝酒睡觉时，他会做可怕的噩梦。在他当选第七次执政官两周后，他死了。
And this grim, terrible old man at last is gone. He dies of what? Booze. Apoplexy, booze, over-excitement. Basically, he's, you know, he's run his course. But he's died as he wanted. His consul, he's drunk, he's killing people. Yeah, he's the master of Rome. He's had his seventh consulship.
这个阴沉、可怕的老人终于走了。他死于什么？酒。中风、酒、过度兴奋。基本上，他，你知道，他走完了他的路。但他死得如他所愿。他的执政官，他喝醉了，他在杀人。是的，他是罗马的主人。他有了他的第七次执政官任期。
I mean, who wouldn't want to be guys? Marius at that point. Brilliant. Loving it. So he leaves behind him as the heir to his cause a son. He is only 22 at this point. He's very good looking. He's a bit of a playboy. And he is utterly committed to continuing the blood feud with Maris's enemies and especially with Sulla. So the Merrians are still on the scene. But the death of Marius effectively means that Sinner is now unchallenged as the leader of this new regime that has taken power in Rome. And the years that follow the death of Marius will be commemorated by the Romans as what they called Kinanum Tempus, the age of sinner. And he will maintain himself in the consulship
我是说，谁不想在那个时候成为盖乌斯·马略呢？太棒了。喜欢它。所以他留下了一个儿子作为他事业的继承人。他此时只有22岁。他长得很帅。他有点花花公子。而且他完全致力于继续与马略的敌人，特别是与苏拉的血仇。所以马略派仍然在场。但马略的死实际上意味着秦纳现在作为这个在罗马掌权的新政权的领导人是无可挑战的。马略死后的岁月将被罗马人纪念为他们所说的“秦纳时代”，秦纳的时代。他将保持执政官职位
for the next three years. So a succession of continuous consulships. And there's no nonsense about keeping his oath to Sulla. Quite the contrary. Everything he does has as its goal, the destruction of his great enemy. And with Sulla absent in the East, Sinha knows that he has a breathing space at least. But they do, you know, he and his regime know what is threatening. They know that if Sulla is successful in his war, you know, should he defeat Mithridates, should he survive to return to Rome with all his legions, then there will be the showdown to end all showdowns.
在接下来的三年里。所以是一连串连续的执政官任期。而且没有关于遵守对苏拉誓言的废话。恰恰相反。他所做的一切目标都是摧毁他的大敌人。由于苏拉在东方缺席，秦纳知道他至少有喘息的空间。但他们确实，你知道，他和他的政权知道什么在威胁着。他们知道如果苏拉在战争中取得成功，你知道，如果他击败了米特里达梯，如果他活着回到罗马并带着他所有的军团，那么就会有终极的对决。
And so unsurprisingly, during these years, sinners' priority is to prepare for the return of Sulla. Okay. So that's what's been going on in Rome. But all this time Sulla has been away in the East prosecuting his war to try to restore Roman hegemony in the Eastern Mediterranean. He started in Macedon, didn't he? Macedon, which is, of course, a Roman province at this point. So how did it go? Well, the reason he's gone to Macedon is he wants to secure it against the threat of that expeditionary force that Mithridates had sent to Athens after the Athenians and Mithridates had signed their treaty.
所以不出所料，在这些年里，秦纳的首要任务是为苏拉的回归做准备。好吧。这就是罗马发生的事情。但所有这些时间苏拉一直在东方进行他的战争，试图恢复罗马在东地中海的霸权。他从马其顿开始，不是吗？马其顿，当然，此时是罗马的一个行省。那么进展如何？好吧，他去马其顿的原因是他想确保它免受米特里达梯在雅典人和米特里达梯签署条约后派往雅典的那支远征军的威胁。
And the arrival of Sala and his army in Macedon is alarming for Mithridates men because they know the calibre of the Romans. And so rather than confront them, they retreat southwards back to Athens. and they hold themselves up in the port of Athens, which is separate from the main body of the city. So the main body of the city of Athens is protected by walls, and so also is the port of Athens, Pereus. That is also surrounded by walls. And it's in the port that Mithridates force embed themselves, because obviously from there, they can be supplied by Mithridates. You know, they have access to the sea. Meanwhile, what of Athens itself? Well, people may remember the guy in charge in Athens is this philosopher Aristion, who has by this point inevitably
而萨拉和他的军队到达马其顿对米特里达梯的人来说是令人震惊的，因为他们知道罗马人的素质。所以他们没有对抗他们，而是向南撤退回雅典。他们把自己关在雅典的港口，这与城市的主体是分开的。所以雅典城市的主体受到城墙的保护，雅典的港口比雷埃夫斯也是如此。它也被城墙包围。米特里达梯的部队就嵌入在港口，因为显然从那里，他们可以得到米特里达梯的补给。你知道，他们可以进入大海。与此同时，雅典本身呢？好吧，人们可能记得负责雅典的人是这个哲学家阿里斯提翁，他此时不可避免地
installed himself as its tyrant. And the situation facing the Athenians now is, I mean, it is a nightmare. So Aristion, I mean, he may be great at giving academic lectures, but the question is, is he any cop at fighting the world's most terrifying military machine? Because I guess success in academia doesn't always mean that you're going to be much cop as a fighter. And does it prove that way for this fellow? So the Athenians wake up one morning to their ultimate nightmare because they found camped out in front of their city walls, an army of vengeful legionaries commanded by Rome's greatest general. This is not what you want to see if you are a citizen of a rebellious Greek city. And especially not if you are a citizen of a city commanded by an academic who I'm afraid to
已经把自己安装为暴君。雅典人现在面临的情况，我是说，这是一场噩梦。所以阿里斯提翁，我是说，他可能很擅长做学术讲座，但问题是，他在对抗世界上最可怕的军事机器方面有什么本事吗？因为我猜学术上的成功并不总是意味着你作为一个战士会很有本事。这对这个家伙来说是这样吗？所以雅典人有一天早上醒来，面对他们的终极噩梦，因为他们发现驻扎在他们城墙前的是一支由罗马最伟大的将军指挥的复仇军团。如果你是一个叛乱的希腊城市的公民，这不是你想看到的。尤其是如果你是一个由一位学者指挥的城市的公民，恐怕我
proves himself sorely unsuited to prosecuting a war against the Romans. So Aristion's approach is to compose rude songs about Sulla's complexion and to teach it to all the Athenians and to get them to chant these songs from the battlements. And Aristion himself yells out assorted witticisms about Sulla and his wife, complete with extravagant hand gestures. So he's like one of those academics on X or Blue Sky. Blue Sky. He's a blue sky person.
证明自己非常不适合进行一场针对罗马人的战争。所以阿里斯提翁的方法是创作关于苏拉肤色的粗鲁歌曲，并教给所有的雅典人，让他们从城墙上高唱这些歌曲。阿里斯提翁本人大声喊出关于苏拉和他妻子的各种俏皮话，并配以夸张的手势。所以他就像X或Blue Sky上的那些学者之一。Blue Sky。他是一个Blue Sky的人。
Who disgraced themselves by getting into abusive slagging matches with their enemies. I can think of so many examples. I mean, it makes me happy just to think of it, to be frank. So this is Aristotle's approach. You know, he has these colleagues, his fellow philosophers who watch this and think it's ridiculous. So there's another philosopher, a guy called Posidonius, who's very keen on Roman rule, thinks it's tremendous. and thought, therefore, that it was obviously mad for the Athenians to oppose the Romans. He completely despises Aristion.
因为与敌人进行辱骂性的争吵而丢脸。我能想到很多例子。我是说，坦率地说，想到它让我很高兴。所以这就是亚里士多德的方法。你知道，他有这些同事，他的哲学家同伴看着这一切并认为这很荒谬。所以有另一个哲学家，一个叫波希多尼的人，他非常热衷于罗马统治，认为这很了不起。因此认为雅典人反对罗马人显然是疯了。他完全鄙视阿里斯提翁。
And he says that Aristion's behaviour is proof that swords should never be placed in the hands of children. So we're possibly being unfair to Aristion, because actually the Athenians under his command, they do put up a very lengthy resistance. But I guess that that probably owes more to fear than to Aristion's leadership qualities. because of course everyone in Athens knows what had happened to Corinth. Corinth had been completely raised. You know, the city had vanished from the face of the earth. And also, I guess they're hoping for reinforcements from Mithridates.
他说阿里斯提翁的行为证明了剑永远不应该放在孩子手中。所以我们可能对阿里斯提翁不公平，因为实际上在他指挥下的雅典人确实进行了非常漫长的抵抗。但我猜这可能更多归功于恐惧而不是阿里斯提翁的领导素质。因为当然雅典的每个人都知道科林斯发生了什么。科林斯被彻底夷为平地。你知道，这座城市从地球表面消失了。而且，我猜他们希望得到米特里达梯的增援。
They're allied to the king. Maybe he will send troops over. But they wait and wait and wait. Nothing arrives. They start to eat shoe leather. They start to eat rats. There are stories that cannibalism starts to be practiced. And finally, Aristion sends a delegation to Sulla to try and negotiate.
他们与国王结盟。也许他会派军队过来。但他们等啊等啊等。什么也没到。他们开始吃鞋皮。他们开始吃老鼠。有故事说开始实行同类相食。最后，阿里斯提翁派了一个代表团去苏拉那里试图谈判
terms. And they do what Athenian ambassadors in a tight corner always do, which is to discourse very windily about the glories of the city's past. And Sulla listens to them do this, and he raises a hand and he silences them. And he says, Rome did not send me here to be lectured on ancient history. Do you know what? I mean, I actually was always on Sulla's team anyway, but I'm even more on it now. He sounds great. Well, Sulla is not, I mean, he's not Pete Hemp. Hegeseth. He's a very cultured, intelligent, literate man. Very, very clever, very intellectual. But he is faced by open rebels against Roman rule. And so he is in no mood to show the glories of Athenian civilization any respect whatsoever. So he needs to build siege engines. So he sends his
条款。他们做了雅典大使在困境中总是做的事情，那就是非常冗长地谈论城市过去的荣耀。苏拉听着他们这样做，他举起一只手，让他们安静下来。他说，罗马派我来这里不是为了听关于古代历史的讲座。你知道吗？我是说，我其实一直都在苏拉的团队里，但我现在更支持他了。他听起来很棒。好吧，苏拉不是，我是说，他不是皮特·亨普。赫格塞斯。他是一个非常有文化、聪明、有学问的人。非常、非常聪明，非常有知识。但他面临的是公开反抗罗马统治的叛乱分子。所以他没有心情对雅典文明的荣耀表现出任何尊重。所以他需要建造攻城器械。所以他派他的
engineers to go and chop down the woods in the groves where Plato and Aristotle had taught philosophy to their students and the wood is used to build siege engines. And when at last, as was always going to happen, in March 86, the Romans break into Athens. Sulla gives his troops full license to do what they want to do. They can kill who they want to kill. They can loot what they want to loot. They can plunder what they want to plunder. And meanwhile, Aristion has flared up to the Acropolis, taken reference there, where he continues
工程师去砍伐柏拉图和亚里士多德教导学生哲学的树林，木材被用来建造攻城器械。当最终，正如总是会发生的那样，在公元前86年3月，罗马人冲进雅典。苏拉给了他的部队完全的许可去做他们想做的事。他们可以杀他们想杀的人。他们可以抢他们想抢的东西。他们可以掠夺他们想掠夺的东西。与此同时，阿里斯提翁已经逃到了卫城，在那里寻求庇护，他继续
to defy Sala, continues to chant his abusive slogan. I mean, absolutely mad behaviour. And inevitably, it doesn't take the Romans long to storm the Acropolis. It too is plundered. And Aristion is clinging to the altar of Athena in the Parthenon. The Romans show that no respect. They drag him away and they force him to drink poison. And that is the end of Aristion.
蔑视萨拉，继续高唱他的辱骂口号。我是说，绝对疯狂的行为。不可避免地，罗马人没过多久就强攻了卫城。它也被掠夺了。阿里斯提翁紧紧抓住帕台农神庙中雅典娜的祭坛。罗马人表现出毫无尊重。他们把他拖走，强迫他喝下毒药。这就是阿里斯提翁的结局。
So meanwhile, what about Mithridates' army, which has been in Piraeus? You described they were holed up in the ports. Have they just been watching and doing nothing the whole time? Basically, yes. because Mithridates hasn't sent them any reinforcements. And instead, what he's done is to raise an absolutely massive army and send that over land. So it's going across the north of Greece and then down through the past of Thermopylae towards Athens. And as it approaches Athens, Mithridates orders the troops who hold up in the port of Athens, Piraeus, to evacuate and to go and join this invasion force.
那么与此同时，一直待在比雷埃夫斯的米特里达梯军队怎么样了？你描述过他们躲在港口里。他们一直只是在旁观，什么都没做吗？基本上是的，因为米特里达梯没有给他们派去任何增援。相反，他所做的是集结了一支极其庞大的军队，并从陆路派了过来。所以它穿过希腊北部，然后经过温泉关隘口向雅典进发。当它接近雅典时，米特里达梯命令躲在雅典港口比雷埃夫斯的军队撤离，去加入这支入侵部队。
So they do this. The port is left empty. The Romans march in. And the port they do absolutely flatten. However, Athens, Sulla decides, he's not going to obliterate Athens. Athens is just, is in the final reckoning, too famous, too celebrated. And so Sulla declares, I spare the living out of respect for the dead. But even though Athens has been spared the fate of Corinth, it is in a terrible state after this siege and after it's captured by Sulla's men.
于是他们照做了。港口被留空了。罗马人开进来了。他们确实把港口彻底夷为平地。然而，苏拉决定，他不会彻底摧毁雅典。雅典毕竟太出名、太受推崇了。因此苏拉宣布，出于对死者的尊重，我饶恕生者。但尽管雅典免于了科林斯的命运，在这次围攻和被苏拉的人占领之后，它处于一种可怕的状态。
The streets are spattered in blood. It's been looted. Every last fig leaf of independence has been stripped away. And the fate of those who had served in Aristion's government is terrible. They're all executed. The supporters of this government are stripped of the vote. The democracy is effectively abandoned. And this really is the end of the Athenian democracy as something that has anything more
街道上溅满了鲜血。它被洗劫一空。独立自主的最后一点遮羞布也被剥去了。那些曾在阿里斯提翁政府中任职的人的命运是可怕的。他们都被处决了。这个政府的支持者被剥夺了投票权。民主实际上被放弃了。这确实是雅典民主作为某种具有任何意义的事物的终结，
than just a kind of antiquarian function. And the wreckage is inherited by all the businessmen who had fled from Athens when the coup happened to Sulla and now they're reinstalled basically as as Roman puppets. And from this point on, Athens is a subject city. It has no future as a power with any pretensions to any influence whatsoever. From this point on, basically, it's going to serve, I suppose it's going to serve Romans as Oxford serves Americans as a kind of, you know, a high-end a finishing school, a kind of, you know, a university town. All right.
除了仅仅是一种古董式的功能。而残局则由所有在政变发生时逃离雅典投奔苏拉的商人们继承，现在他们基本上被重新安插为罗马的傀儡。从这一点开始，雅典成了一个附属城市。它作为一个有任何影响力企图的强权已没有未来。从这一点开始，基本上，它将服务于——我想它将服务于罗马人，就像牛津服务于美国人一样，作为一种，你知道，高端的精修学校，一种，你知道，大学城。好吧。
So that's the end of Athens. That's sad. But Sulla and Mithridart is an invasion force. Presumably they are now heading for a bit of a showdown, are they? Because there's two big armies in Greece and there's only room for one of them. Well, there's one absolutely colossal army and then the Sulla's army, which is hugely outnumbered. However, the Romans have never lost a major pitched battle in Greece. And Sulla is, you know, he's a man who backs himself.
所以这就是雅典的终结。这很悲哀。但苏拉和米特里达梯的入侵部队，大概他们现在正走向一场决战，是吗？因为希腊有两支大军，而那里只能容得下一支。嗯，有一支绝对庞大的军队，然后是苏拉的军队，人数处于极大的劣势。然而，罗马人在希腊从未输过一场重大的阵地战。而苏拉，你知道，他是一个对自己有信心的人。
We know this by now. And so he marches out very coolly. He meets Mithridates invasion force. It's been divided into two. Sulla annihilates both of them. And that's the end of Mithridates invasion force. And it's done very quickly and brutally. That was quick.
我们现在已经知道了。所以他非常冷静地进军。他遇到了米特里达梯的入侵部队。它被分成了两部分。苏拉歼灭了这两部分。这就是米特里达梯入侵部队的终结。而且完成得非常迅速和残酷。那真是快。
That essentially is the end of the war. Sulla has done what he set out to do. He's taken Athens back and he has destroyed Mithridates' offensive capability. And he opens negotiations with the general of this invasion force who survived the the defeat. And then the following autumn, amazingly, he meets with Mithridates in person on the shores of the Hellespot, so up by Gallipoli. And this is very unusual behaviour from a Roman, because the Romans do not usually negotiate with the kind of person who might have been responsible for wiping out tens of thousands of their compatriots, which is what Mithridates had done. But actually,
这基本上就是战争的结束。苏拉完成了他设定的目标。他夺回了雅典，并摧毁了米特里达梯的进攻能力。他与这支入侵部队中幸存下来的将军开启了谈判。然后在接下来的秋天，令人惊讶的是，他在赫勒斯滂海峡的岸边，也就是加里波利附近，亲自会见了米特里达梯。这在罗马人中是非常不寻常的行为，因为罗马人通常不会与那种可能应对屠杀数万名同胞负责的人进行谈判，而这正是米特里达梯所做的。但实际上，
both men have good reason to reach terms. So for Mithridates, I mean, he knows the game is up. He's lost all his troops. He'll be lucky to survive. And if he can reach terms with Sala, then that's tremendous for him. That effectively, in the situation that he's in, is a result. Equally, Sulla doesn't have time to finish Mithridates off. He really urgently needs to get back to Italy.
两人都有充分的理由达成协议。对于米特里达梯来说，我的意思是，他知道大势已去。他失去了所有的军队。他能活下来就算走运了。如果他能与苏拉达成协议，那对他来说就是巨大的收获。实际上，在他所处的这种情况下，这就是一个结果。同样，苏拉也没有时间去彻底消灭米特里达梯。他非常迫切地需要回到意大利。
because as we've been hearing, things have not been developing in Italy necessarily to Sulla's advantage. Because by this point, he has been declared a public enemy by Sina and his regime. And he's been condemned to death, his property has been raised, and his family and his supporters have been forced to flee. So when Mithridates says to Sulla, look, this is what I'll do. I will withdraw from all the Roman territory that I had conquered. So effectively, the province of Asia, I will give it back to you. You can have all the cities. I will withdraw to the limits of the kingdom of Pontus.
因为正如我们一直听到的那样，意大利的情况并不一定朝着对苏拉有利的方向发展。因为到这个时候，他已经被秦纳及其政权宣布为公敌。他被判处死刑，他的财产被没收，他的家人和支持者被迫逃亡。所以当米特里达梯对苏拉说，看，我会这样做。我将从我征服的所有罗马领土上撤出。所以实际上，亚细亚行省，我会把它还给你。你可以拥有所有的城市。我将撤退到本都王国的边界内。
And I will accept Roman weapons inspectors coming in to make sure that I'm behaving myself, that I'm not kind of redeveloping my offensive capabilities. Hans blicks. Yes, handsless blixers. And Sulla says, okay, and he gives the killer of all these Romans and Italians a peck on the cheek and the treaty is signed. And this is a massive result for Mithridates, because no one ever, has emerged so unscathed from a war with the Republic.
并且我将接受罗马武器核查人员的到来，以确保我循规蹈矩，确保我没有在重新发展我的进攻能力。汉斯·布利克斯（Hans Blix）。是的，汉斯·布利克斯们。苏拉说，好吧，他给了这个杀害了所有这些罗马人和意大利人的凶手一个脸颊上的吻，条约就签署了。这对米特里达梯来说是一个巨大的成果，因为从来没有人能从与共和国的战争中如此毫发无损地脱身。
I mean, this is a really good result for him. I mean, the people for whom it's a disaster are the Greek cities of Asia, because these are all the guys who personally slaughtered all the Roman and Italian businessman, and now they've come back under Roman rule. So they have a terrible time of it, because not only do they have to pay five years back tax, but they're also obliged to pay the full costs of the war and the costs of the Roman garrisons,
我的意思是，这对他是非常好的结果。我的意思是，对他来说是灾难的人是亚细亚的希腊城市，因为这些人都是亲自屠杀了所有罗马和意大利商人的家伙，现在他们又回到了罗马的统治之下。所以他们过得很惨，因为他们不仅要补缴五年的税款，而且还被迫支付战争的全部费用以及罗马驻军的费用，
that Sulla slaps on them. So they go back to being leached white of their cash, which is what had been happening before Mithridates invasion. On the other hand, though, if you're living in Asia, it's a sign that you can fight the Romans and get away with it. I don't think that is the lesson they draw. Okay. I think the lesson they draw is don't mess with the Romans,
苏拉强加给他们的。所以他们又回到了被榨干钱财的状态，这正是米特里达梯入侵前发生的事情。但另一方面，如果你住在亚细亚，这是一个信号，表明你可以对抗罗马人并侥幸逃脱。我不认为这是他们吸取的教训。好吧。我认为他们吸取的教训是不要招惹罗马人，
and they will not mess with the Romans ever and again. You know, they have learned their lesson. As too has Athens, because after he's sorted out, Asia, Sulla returns across the Aegean to Athens and there he inflicts further humiliations on the city. I mean, a little bit, I mean, always dangerous to compare people from history to Nazis. But there is a slight element of guring turning up and having the pick of an art gallery to what Sulla does next. So there is this great unfinished temple to Zeus, which has been taken centuries and centuries to complete.
他们将永远不会再招惹罗马人。你知道，他们已经吸取了教训。雅典也是如此，因为在处理完亚细亚后，苏拉穿过爱琴海回到雅典，在那里他对这座城市施加了进一步的羞辱。我的意思是，有一点，我的意思是，将历史人物与纳粹进行比较总是很危险的。但苏拉接下来的行为中确实有一点戈林出现并挑选艺术画廊藏品的成分。所以这里有这座伟大的未完成的宙斯神庙，它已经花费了几个世纪的时间来建造。
And so Sulla pulls down all the various columns of this temple and has them ready to be transported to Rome. He also loots the city's libraries of all their holdings. So henceforward, if philosophers like Aristion want to study the original manuscripts of Aristotle, they'll have to go to Rome. And I think that this is a very pointed insult from Sulla at the academic community in Athens. And he also rounds up a large number of Greek athletes so that they can feature in the triumph that is planning. And the Olympics are actually left so denuded of star quality that in the next Olympics they can only stage the sprint every,
于是苏拉拆毁了这座神庙的所有各种柱子，并准备将它们运往罗马。他还洗劫了城市图书馆的所有藏书。因此从今往后，如果像阿里斯提翁这样的哲学家想要研究亚里士多德的原始手稿，他们就必须去罗马。我认为这是苏拉对雅典学术界的一个非常尖锐的侮辱。他还围捕了大量的希腊运动员，以便他们能出现在他计划的凯旋式中。而奥运会实际上被剥夺得如此缺乏明星素质，以至于在下一届奥运会上他们只能举办短跑比赛，
all the other competitors. So, it's over so quickly anyway. Boring. Yeah. So probably the worst Olympics ever. But of course, you know,
所有其他的竞争者。所以，反正结束得太快了。无聊。是的。所以这可能是史上最糟糕的奥运会。但当然，你知道，
is Sala counting his chickens before they've hatched by planning a triumph? He has been declared a public enemy. So in constitutional terms, his command is illegal. And not only that, But Sinha, who is by far the ablest of his enemies, back in Italy, he is planning an expedition from Italy across the Adriatic to Greece to confront Sulla before Sulla can cross the Adriatic and come to Italy. So that massive showdown that both sides have been anticipating for much of
苏拉在计划凯旋式时是不是在还没孵出小鸡之前就先数鸡蛋了？他已经被宣布为公敌。所以在宪法层面上，他的指挥权是非法的。不仅如此，秦纳，他是他敌人中能力最强的一个，回到意大利，他正在计划从意大利跨越亚得里亚海到希腊的远征，以便在苏拉跨越亚得里亚海来到意大利之前对抗苏拉。所以双方在这一集的大部分时间里一直预料的那场大规模决战，
this episode, Rome's first full-blown civil war, that is now imminent. It is going to happen. Wow. So we are building towards the great showdown. And in the next episode, our climactic episode of this series, we will find out what happens to Sulla. Will he make himself master of Rome? Will he celebrate his triumph? And what then? And of course, this is the key step, you might argue, looking back towards the establishment of a new kind of Rome, an imperial Rome, a generation or two later. So there's only one way to find out what happens, and that's to listen to the next episode. There's literally no other way that you will find out the story. There are no other historical accounts of this. There will just be the Restis History's account. Now, if you're a member of the Restis History Club, you can listen to that final episode right now. If you're not a member of the club, if you've identified what the winning side is, and you want to be on it, you don't want to be prescribed and have your property seized, then I would suggest you go to the Restishistory.com, sign up.
罗马第一次全面的内战，现在迫在眉睫了。它将会发生。哇。所以我们正在走向那场伟大的决战。在下一集，我们这个系列的终极一集里，我们将找出苏拉会发生什么。他会让自己成为罗马的主人吗？他会庆祝他的凯旋式吗？然后呢？当然，这是关键的一步，你可能会说，回顾一下，朝着建立一种新的罗马，一种帝国罗马，一两代人之后。所以只有一个方法可以找出发生了什么，那就是收听下一集。字面上没有其他方法可以让你找出这个故事。没有其他关于此的历史记载。只有《剩余的历史》的记载。现在，如果你是《剩余的历史》俱乐部的成员，你现在就可以收听最后一集。如果你不是俱乐部的成员，如果你已经确定了哪一方是获胜的一方，并且你想站在那一边，你不想被列入公敌名单并被没收财产，那么我建议你去Restishistory.com，注册。
you'll get the final episode, you get a host of unbelievable additional benefits, but also you'll have the satisfaction of knowing you're on the right side of history, the winning side. You are not a member of Marius's party. So I encourage you to do that. I also encourage you to sign up for the rest of history's free newsletter. It's completely free and it has all kinds of fascinating articles about this story and other stories, feedback from listeners and all kinds of things like that.
你将获得最后一集，你将获得大量令人难以置信的额外福利，而且你还会有一种满足感，知道你站在了历史正确的一边，获胜的一边。你不是马略党的人。所以我鼓励你这样做。我也鼓励你注册《剩余的历史》的免费通讯。它是完全免费的，并且有各种关于这个故事和其他故事的迷人文章，来自听众的反馈以及各种各样的事情。
So it's absolutely brilliant. Tom, I actually can't wait to find. find out what happens to Sulla. So I'm going off now. I'm going off now to listen to that final episode. Bye-bye. Very wise. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以它绝对精彩。汤姆，我真的等不及要找出苏拉发生了什么。所以我现在要走了。我现在要走了去听最后一集。再见。非常明智。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。